Appearing at the Atlanta Improv October 16th 17th and eight that's how my
daughter does punchlines.
My former,
my four year old rather,
I former,
my four year old daughter,
she goes,
what kind of tree grows in your hand?
Are Palm trees and then she'll hit the same punchline over and over again and
over.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
Do it really.
I want do it with formality.
I want enthusiasms appearing at the Ed.
Less improper.
It's the one and only Brian motherfucking Callan.
October 16th 17th and 18th got Tim and I have to sneeze.
No Way.
The kid,
the kid,
what did in the middle of might,
I'm going to Ah dammit.
In the middle.
Brian Killen by the kid.
I'll be the crash signed the kid.
No way in person.
I hear his weapon or looking at super athletic.
He's beautiful here.
The way he moves moves on the inside,
I don't mean is,
but I mean soul adorable.
October 16th 17th 18th the Atlanta Improv,
if it's like any of the other Improv's.
It's awesome.
The improv is the premiere comedy club chain in the country.
And if you nowhere near Atlanta,
if you happen to be in Philadelphia or Washington DC,
I'm at the tower theater on Friday,
October 7th in Philadelphia and then um,
at the Warner theater on Friday,
Saturday rather October 18th.
Both of those gigs,
the October 18th one to Washington DC,
the Warner theater in Washington DC.
Both those gigs are with Ian Edwards.
So the 17 Marion Philadelphia,
oh,
he's awesome.
Fucking awesome.
High level headliner.
So Philadelphia,
October 17th and then Washington DC,
October 18th.
That's for me and Brian Callan is October 16th,
17th and 18th.
And Brian Cowan is back and mother fucking seven
five days in the rain,
sleeping on a slant,
poo it outside.
I'm not sick,
but I do have something going on in my nose.
It's the,
it's an La air.
After all that pristine that dropped off 1300 feet above sea level in a sea
plane,
it took three plants in a sea plane,
get dropped off on a lake,
a mountain lake that you could drink out of,
which we did drink.
We drank out of the link.
That's how clean it is.
Yeah,
it's a May.
It's rainwater.
Yeah.
It's made of rain.
There's not even any fish in that lake,
which is really crazy.
It's weird,
right?
It's a huge lake and it's,
there's no rivers that go into it and there's also several leaks on Prince of
Wales island.
I mean,
maybe there's a couple of fish in there I don't know about,
but we didn't see any clear crystal clear water and there's several layers,
like some of them were up high and other ones are like,
you know,
a few hundred feet below it.
There's another lake.
It's really weird.
Also when you were hiking through that terrain,
you'll cut through the woods and like just cut it through this rain forest and
then you just come across this clearing with another little pond or lake.
It's like shooting a lot,
man.
Everywhere.
This legs,
it gets more rain,
more rainfall than any other place in America.
It's 160 inches of rainfall.
Apparently Rinella said it's one of the biggest islands in America next to the
Hawaiian islands.
It's bigger than the big Hawaii Island at Prince of Wales.
Islands I believe is actually,
that's what our friend Matt said.
Crazy.
That's what Matt said,
but I believe Rinella said it was half the size of the hole.
Okay,
let's find out.
Let's find out how big it is.
Prince of Wales.
We spend our entire time and basically wet.
Even though you're wearing what?
Rain care and nothing dries out.
Nothing.
First Day of my shirt got wet.
It never dried out.
You know,
it's the fourth largest island after Hawaii,
Kodiak,
and it's one 10th the size of Ireland.
Whoa.
Slightly larger than the state of Delaware.
It's crazy.
And oh by the Oh and and and very important.
Didn't see any,
didn't see any beer.
You'd be,
he'd be funny.
It's a huge island man.
Three planes to get there.
I'm looking through my binoculars.
How many deer?
I saw one.
Yeah,
there was two dose,
which I couldn't shoot.
We,
it was not one we can according to Rinella.
We went there at a bad time,
which is fucking weird.
Since he was the guy hosting the Goddamn show with right.
That means the deer,
even the deer were like,
this sucks.
Let's go to the deer were like,
it's
too rainy and windy.
Here let's,
let's move down.
Even the deer,
we're like,
see Yah.
Yeah.
The deer went towards the ocean.
Can humans with their fire sticks?
We,
uh,
we saw very few animals,
but it was still unbelievably beautiful and it was so clean.
That's the weirdest thing about the air there was so clean that when we got to
la,
we both were like,
Ooh,
we smelled the air and was like panic.
My nose closed up immediately.
The real remember at the airport,
I mean granted we were in traffic,
but I,
I was shocked.
My system went,
what started closing down?
Well,
we were breathing in this moist,
clear air,
drinking clean water,
but I'll take this over that every fucking day of the week.
First of all,
just want to get that out of the way.
Like especially because we didn't have a house,
we were camping and if you've ever camped in the rain,
you might be able to pull it off for a day.
Might be able to pull it off for two days,
but once you start getting into that fifth day,
oh God is it suck a fat one.
You know what was happening to me,
I became,
I was becoming like a fetish fetishistic whatever the word is about my gear,
like how,
how to keep everything dry and I was even like making my sandwiches secretly in
the tent.
I would steal away meant when you said you were like,
were you making sandwiches?
I was like,
Huh,
Huh.
You took mayonnaise and bread and meat and went into your tent and I hit and I
was like,
fuck those guys.
I'm eating a sandwich.
I'll eat the dry asphalt.
I was turning on the whole camp.
Well,
I got a little bit better at figuring out how to deal with the rain,
but at one point,
you know where these headlamps,
so they're like,
they're like,
like a mining hat sort of thing.
On the top of your forehead you have this light and it's a catch for a strap and
I turned it on.
I turned my strap on inside the tent and it was like a sea of do like the inside
of the tent,
like everywhere you look,
it was like it was raining.
These microscopic drops of water.
It was like looking out into a downpour,
a microscopic drop downpour.
So there's these tiny little drips everywhere,
but the inside of the tent was filled with moisture.
Everything.
Your sleeping bag was wet.
I sleeping bag but had a sheen I do under grace.
It's really fun to sleep in that.
Oh,
it's a good time.
You could take your hand and you rub it over the top of my sleeping bag in your
hand would be wet and the inside was wet like my hands got wet.
Wool is fucking amazing.
Yup.
Okay.
If you're wearing cotton out there in this kind of weather,
you're really fucked.
But wool is an incredible material when you're wearing wool.
Wool somehow know that even if the clothes are wet,
you retain heat.
Yeah.
It's really the oils and the wall,
I guess.
And also we'll wicks away moisture from the body for whatever reason,
but does it because I get it must,
I don't know.
It must wick away but not tries quickly.
You ever notice that?
Like apparently it dries quickly,
but they say cotton kills.
If you're in wet cold environments and you're hiking whatever and you were
caught and you will,
that's how people die.
Yeah,
because you sweat.
Yeah.
And then you get wet and then you get freezing cold.
Like we were in a constant state of when you're hiking,
first of all,
we're s we're following you weren't,
but I was following Steve,
the Billy goat Rinella.
Okay.
This fucker does this shit 365 days a year.
I'm lucky that I'm in good shape.
And uh,
lucky also that I work my legs out like crazy.
Yeah.
Those poor guys like,
oh grocery skipped leg day.
You ever see those guys?
They look like a meatball with to,
they'd be two sticks.
They'd be fucked.
Terrible hunting bodies.
Yeah.
I worked my legs out more than any other part of my body because the kickboxing
and I just am always doing squats.
And noisy,
so my legs really didn't get tired even though it was five days of pretty
intense hiking.
But my cardio got tested seriously and I was sweating like a fucking pig.
So you'd get to the top of this.
First of all,
I didn't layer it right like when we talked to my team,
uh,
one of our friends that we met down there,
shout out to [inaudible],
shout out 10 prints,
all the
other,
another shout out to shout out Guy Friend Dui are a are our English friend,
Dean.
Great fucking guy.
All the people there.
Mike,
Shout out to Mike from Austin.
Cool fucking crew just to give a shout out to fucking awesome Dan Dodi.
Everybody is beautiful.
It's a great cat.
Like we had a fucking legitimately awesome time and it's one of the most
miserable conditions,
the world.
We laughed,
we laughed the whole time.
Other than like freezing cold,
the it's the most miserable because you're just drenched all the time.
Yeah,
I guess actually I would take that honestly over like desert conditions,
like 130 degrees because there's no water.
But my hands were pruning.
My hands were so wet for so long for get gloves.
By the way your hands are just going to do,
don't.
Yeah it does look like they've been in the pool for two days.
But those again,
those first light,
those wool gloves,
the fucking wall.
Even though your hands are wet,
it keeps your hands warm.
It's really weird.
I don't know how it works.
Well for first light is a company that sponsors a I l.
I t e first light,
they sponsor midi to podcast.
We've got a bunch of their gear and our friend Brian Callahan works for them and
everything they make is Merino wool.
And I was like why my mom?
This is Whoa,
what the fuck is will will is the shit the shit in cold weather you got to get
wool and layer,
layer down cause you keep warm.
Actually people were really tight.
Stuff is the wrong thing to do.
You want to keep an air pocket around your body.
That's how animals keep warm.
So Martin was telling me you should really wear very little when you go out and
then keep everything else in your pack.
That would have been the smart thing to do.
I didn't do it that way.
I put all the layers on so by the time I got to the top of the mountain,
I'm fucking,
I'm literally drenched.
My legs are drenched,
my upper body's drench.
And then you have to sit down and eat glass.
So Glassy means you use your binoculars.
We sit down and looking for dear.
Oh dear.
Oh No.
Okay.
So we're sitting there looking for deer,
freezing my dick completely off.
And you do well on the call.
But I as the first time I've ever seen you shiver like you are shaking.
You are so called one time when we,
I think it was the morning you came in and you were like,
because you had been,
you'd been spent all night wet and you came in and I was like,
I was like,
I knew you were too much to say anything,
but I was literally like,
get him,
get him a thermos full of hot water to put it in his jacket.
Cause he's,
I actually got a little protective over.
Aw Sweetie.
Well you were like,
you were shaking man.
Yeah,
that's definitely share.
It was no joke.
It was cold.
I mean in the morning it was probably in the forties.
It was,
it was not the most fun being wet and cold.
But I'm telling you,
it's better than being hot is as weird as it sounds.
It's sucks a fat dick.
But you could warm up just by running up hills.
Like if I wanted to,
like while I was freezing,
I could've just went,
fuck,
fuck.
And just went running up a hill and I would have been warmed by the time I got
to the top of the hill.
Yeah,
I would have been sweating again,
but the art that,
that there is an art to learning how to,
like Martine said,
you climbed them out and he'll client at the top of the mount of t shirt and one
layer sweats,
takes that tee shirt right off and puts two layers on that.
Or a guy that's more,
puts that tee shirt back on when it's come time to come down and look,
we did this shit for on purpose.
We did it for fun,
for the adventure because we love Rinella and we love the show and all the guys
in the show,
but those fucking camera,
those guys who work on that show,
Mike and dean and and and well Dodi's a producer,
but then Dodi's also cameramen,
those guys that work on that show Dodi's a director to now and a producer.
Yeah,
but those guys that work on that fucking show,
God damn,
they have a hard job.
Yeah,
they do those guys and they're just getting paid.
They're getting paid.
That's what they do every week.
Every week they're camping somewhere.
Freezing.
Yeah.
Hungry.
You know where they're going next.
They go to the jungle,
they're going down to fuck Olivia or something.
Some crazy shit.
We're bugs boob where you get where I said Dan has other things to worry about
it.
He goes,
he's been in the Amazon number times.
oh yeah.
I said like what?
He goes,
snakes,
spiders,
Scorpions and bugs you'd never seen before.
Bucks can change your life.
Don't know about,
by the way,
whenever Brian counts here,
see the self to death.
I,
it's contagious.
It's like Hashtag by the way,
it's like when Brody Stevens is here,
you go enjoy it.
Hadn't Joanie?
Yes.
You can't help yourself.
But they had that banana spider down there,
right?
Or is that an in the Philippines?
I don't know.
I mean they have a lot of fucked up spiders in the Amazon.
They have thousands of things that people have never even discovered.
They're always finding new species of bugs down there.
Things that defy explanation.
They bugs.
Man,
I'm,
I'm not a fan.
I'm okay with other stuff.
I'm not,
I'm not okay with bugs.
Like I like,
I'll deal with like grizzlies,
like okay,
there's a grizzly amount.
You'd be scared,
but bugs are the intangible,
like some huge stinging wasp that can fuck that.
Or a spider that puts you in a necrosis.
I can,
you know like the Brown,
the Brown recluse,
your,
your skin starts to decay.
Jeremy Horn had one of those and it left like a golf ball sized hole in his leg.
He left the fucking hole,
just ate through his leg.
Fair de Lance.
What?
When it was snakes bite you?
That happens.
You have to to got bit in the foot by federal lands,
which means,
which by the way I believe means sort of fire fell.
Denounce his French feminists
that don't just sound spell Donelle so cell phone theft,
no nose.
By the way,
Bryan County did several characters over the time.
One of the reasons why I love going on these trips at Brian is because it
becomes a giant five day comedy and becomes a Brian Count shelter.
It's my,
it's a captive audience.
You're not going anywhere.
You're going to go,
but it's also your style of humor.
It's like that's what you do.
Like when there's a group of guys around all of a sudden,
I mean you would think that you would get tired of gay jokes after five days.
No,
because he's got a bunch of different gay characters.
The Russian,
the Russian who makes you eat salad for many days for reflux.
You in the ass cause he wants your asshole clean,
clean asshole.
You have to have to,
we have to keep it clean.
You know,
has clean eat it,
just sell it.
I smack you this,
this video of him explaining to Steve Rinella what he wants Reno's diet to be
like.
Dodi's thinking of a,
putting it online like somehow or another,
figuring out do it online,
do it an unnamed way.
It's mostly because I have you as an audience and there's your one of the best
laughers I just realized that after knowing me for 20 years,
I was like,
you know what?
I think he might be one of the greatest laughers cause you,
you cackle you literally,
when you're laughing you literally go,
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
I,
it's seductive to me.
I'm literally,
and then those guys or those guys are such good audiences to,
well it's just,
you know,
we were talking about how some comedians are just not good at being like an
audience member.
And one of the things that when Brian and I first met Brian was on this show
called mad TV and I was a guest on the show and Brian and I were hanging out in
the cafeteria,
we eat dinner and while we were eating dinner,
Brian was making me laugh.
It was cracking me up,
but we were with a few other actors and instead of laughing at Brian,
they were trying to one up him and I was like,
oh this is so gross.
Like you can't even just let a guy be funny.
Like it's one thing if like comedy in those certain circumstances it's like
it's,
it's totally intuitive thing.
It's like you have to know if you actually have something funny to say or not.
Again,
if,
if there's something funny that you can do,
you've got to feel it and you just got to run with it and no one can understand
it.
No one,
no one can explain when something's going to be funny and when something's not
going to be fun.
It's completely,
totally instinctive.
But what these guys were doing was like being like ultra super calculated and
competitive.
They weren't really listening right now are being affected.
I was thinking about,
you know,
it's,
it's very underrated quality when you have a friend who can really laugh at at
things.
Oh yeah.
It was really fun thing to have around.
Yeah.
Bravo is great for that.
That's a really,
you know,
that's a really,
really pleasant thing to be.
My,
my sister was my first audience.
My sister couldn't laugh her ass off at things that she was.
I remember as a kid her laughing really hard at me cackling and I was like,
oh,
I think I might be fun.
That was the first,
that was the first thing where I was like,
my sister actually lasts.
I mean,
maybe I can do this.
You know?
It's funny,
man.
That's funny.
So from Montana to Wisconsin to now,
well we failed in this attempt.
This is the only time,
well I shouldn't say that cause the TV show's gonna air.
Whoops.
Cat's out of the bag.
Great show.
Either way,
it's going to be a lot of fun.
But we had a great time in every circumstance.
Like even though we're in like one of the worst,
most uncomfortable positions you could find yourself in like co constantly
drenched.
No hope in sight.
You're only hope for like shelter is this cloth house that you're sleeping in.
That's the size of a small car.
You know you're climbing into a VW bug that's a cloth house and inside at your
wet and that's your shelter and it's not an even surface.
Good luck finding an even surface in Alaska.
Everything hurt too,
man.
Like when I would get up,
my back would hurt,
my neck would hurt,
my shoulders would hurt cause I have to sleep on my side,
you know,
so I'm,
the first two days I was so tired from hiking my,
my legs and my hips because I hadn't had any,
I'm not as stout as you are simply not a stout.
What's I prepared for this?
Remember when I was going to bed?
You're like,
you're going to bed.
I was like,
no,
I'm just going to go to my,
I have to just work on,
I'm going to go,
just read.
I have to take care of something.
I was literally out,
dude.
Yeah,
you were snoring.
Um,
I really prepared for this.
Like I'm,
I always work out,
but I did a lot of,
um,
a stair climber for this Dick.
Man.
I didn't do shit.
And of course you did.
It's smart.
And I did a lot of lip tickle on like very,
uh,
like I put the elliptical on like number 21,
and just talking to her
and I'll do sprints.
Yeah.
Well,
I knew,
I knew I should've just run hills with a pack on my back.
Well also I did a lot of body weight squats,
body weight squats and pistol squats,
pistol squats,
important because there's a lot of times you're picking yourself up with one
leg,
you know,
like your,
uh,
your,
we were first of all ruined.
I don't know how you guys did it,
but Rinella will climb up some treacherous fucking surfaces there.
Well,
they told me that [inaudible] told me that we were moving at a strata of Sim of
simple pace,
like not a high paced.
He goes and he said,
you have no idea how fast he goes,
if you ever been with right now.
I said,
no.
you have no idea how fast he moves.
And,
and that's when I said I,
he said,
we were literally at a moving at our own time.
We'll,
Remi really Warren,
I don't know if they've ever tested Rinella,
is cardio,
but Remy who's also a big time hunter,
he hunts 300 days a year.
He's got that show solo hunter and he's got to a few shows that he's working on
right now with Dan Dodi,
the fascinating guy.
Um,
but he's,
his cardio is so good.
It's that like elite endurance athlete levels.
Like they tested his cardio and his vo two Max is like off the charts and it's
because he's usually got a hundred pounds of elk on his back and he's climbing
uphill and it's 9,000 fucking feet elevation.
And he's,
he does that all the time.
It's crazy.
He lives in Reno and he's,
he does a lot of his hunt there.
A lot of his hunter mountain hunts.
He does mountain Hudson,
New Zealand during the off season.
He's constantly climbing up mountains.
Yeah.
So your,
your lung capacity,
your ability to kind of shape,
it's a different thing because you're also doing it all day.
What will fit now was telling me that he took these bodybuilders out with them,
these powerlifter guys,
and then there's a big strong guys and you know,
so like what we're going to do is going to require,
you know,
a lot of endurance and it's like guys like,
we're fine,
we're in incredible shape.
Don't worry about it.
He said literally 30 minutes in,
they were throwing up 30 minutes in.
Wow.
He's like,
this is a long day.
Like do you understand that we're going to do this for eight hours?
And you're throwing up because when you have,
if you look at a guy like Rinella,
okay,
Rinella probably weighs one seven 65 one 70 somewhere around there.
He's a leaning naming,
yeah.
Lean and thin and been doing it his whole life.
And his specialty is mountain hunting.
So he's constantly climbing,
which is great because he can give you all the tips on like gear and what,
what kind of shoe that makes a big goddamn different types to different types of
shoes.
One cause I knew that they were probably gonna get soaked and one which worked
out really good that she sneeze and these other ones well and won't name that
suck the fat one.
They were terrible.
They just were slippery.
They didn't have the same kind of grip.
And you know if you listen to reno he'll like give you like the low down and
this is the shit to where get this because of that,
get that because of this.
But his body is,
doesn't have a lot of mass,
you know,
I weigh 30 pounds more than him,
so I'm sure that him,
I weigh 30 pounds more than him and I'm carrying a pack and a gun and all these
things I'm not used to.
And you know,
you're constantly trying to go like if you're bigger than that,
like a big power will builder guy,
a big power lifter one was 250 pound characters.
That extra 50 pounds,
we'll fucking SAP your heart.
Man.
Did they do,
how did he,
how did they do?
Yeah,
they were throwing up a half an hour in there were done.
He's like literally they were like,
you know,
an hour into the trip,
they're stopped hands on their knees.
You don't train is different body type.
Well,
power lifters are terrible.
Like when you,
you see him like doing Jujitsu,
it's got Marius [inaudible].
No,
he is super fucked man in the world for a while,
but just unbelievable.
Brute of a man started fighting MMA and Tim Silvia who has like,
Tim's a great fighter but he does not have a good body,
you know?
Sorry Tim.
I feel this way.
I mean look,
he when he was in his best shape like versus Rico Rodriguez when he won the UFC
heavyweight title Ultra Lombard.
In other words,
it's just genetic.
It's just genetic.
It's a ton of percent genetic.
Mean pigeon toed.
That's genetic.
I mean I think Kelly star it says that it's not,
he's probably right.
I've always felt like people who walk like that,
it's just the way they're born.
But yeah,
I bet that could be corrected and he thinks it's emulating.
Kelly Kelly who created this crazy ball do,
you're supposed to roll on your back.
This Wad,
I forget what this is called.
Workout of the day.
I forgot what that's called.
Supernova.
That's what's called this is the latest and greatest of those things that your
role on to massage your back.
Oh,
I bought three of these.
They're fucking amazing.
I don't want to go anywhere without one.
Yeah.
One of 'em [inaudible] students gave me this and uh,
I just started ordering them to leave them in the office,
lead him around the house there is awesome.
But um,
anyway,
Sylvia who is not a bodybuilder and he's not a power lifter,
he's just a really strong guy.
He fought,
puts Nowicki and beat the shit out of him cause he tired of him,
dragged him into deep water and then fucked him up.
But put you analyses,
goddamn crazy for challenging Tim Silvia,
former UFC heavyweight champion afterlife.
That is nuts.
You have like two MMA fights,
light him up and he built like this.
It's really weird.
He was talking about this because today I,
my wife was having breakfast with um,
uh,
the wife of two former NFL,
like grates are really good players.
Giants,
Andre Carter,
who played for 13 years as a defensive end,
he six,
five to 50.
It looks like he doesn't,
he's just like a different kind of human being.
And Marvell Smith who was d tackle for the Steelers for like 10 years and they
want to come hunting.
She was like,
oh,
they would love to come hunting.
And the first thing I thought it was these men are two 50 and 320 pounds or
whatever it respectively.
And I don't know if they can,
and with their knees after playing football for 13 years,
it's going to be very hard for them to climb a mountain.
A lot of those guys,
they're done when they're old,
different.
It's,
you know,
it's just a different guy.
It's also when you have damage to those primary joints,
hips and knees,
you know,
you really see like the,
the loss of mobility is pretty goddamn substantial.
Although apparently they have pretty amazing new artificial knees.
Like they're getting better and better at it.
Yeah,
dude,
they're growing.
Dick's what?
Yes.
I just tweeted it today and they've done this for folks who have,
um,
you know,
like issues,
micro phalluses or mutilation injury,
a circumcision,
injuries,
things along those lines,
which is yeah.
Anything along those lines.
So they're growing ticks.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
Jamie,
if you go to my Twitter tweeter,
um,
there's a dude named Vincent Salazar who,
uh,
Vincent Salads are 11,
and it says a,
it may not be his,
his tweet to me is,
it may not be a pill,
but it will be a boob job for men.
I don't know what he meant,
but maybe their laboratory,
they grown.
Tina says tissue the way they do with the other tissue.
I didn't read it,
I gave it a cursory glance,
but apparently there are about five years away from the small there.
I want to,
well,
these are just cells.
[inaudible] cells.
They're,
I mean,
they're five years away from being able to grow laboratory dicks.
I want something with halfed that that folds over when I'm holding it to pay,
I want it to fold like in half.
I want to have a lot leftover.
What about this,
would you take like say,
do you think the dudes who have like medium sized Dicks,
I'm going to take a chance and get their Dick lopped off and get a new one put
on hold.
Don't that their body's going to accept it.
That's a very,
very um,
sacred part of a man,
right?
I mean that's,
that's a huge,
like if you were going into that as a venture capitalist with the assumption
that men would do that,
I would tell you not to put your money into it.
I would tell you to put your money into it because there's some dudes out there
with some one inch decks.
Well that's a whole different story.
But if you have a medium deck yet,
imagine,
you know,
a medium Deca,
cause my mom,
she got to do something giant.
But there was a guy,
there's this guy that uh,
it was a performance artist and part of his performance art was that he would
take all his clothes off and he had a dick that was,
and I'm not bullshitting the size of the last digit of my pinky.
It was incorrect.
It was sending enough acting classes and seen enough nude scenes and there are
some dudes and one dude,
it was just a macho guy.
He was a hairdresser and he did a naked scene and I am telling you,
I am telling you,
I can see just the head of it in a,
in a sea of black hair,
we used to have fear factor and there was a naked fear factor,
the one and only naked fear factor where we got in trouble for it because we
made these people do a naked fashion show where they took their clothes off.
They went out in the runway and he spun around and this one guy who's just
fucking yoked up,
dude looked like it was a like a macho guy.
He hit the tiny as well and he talked about it beforehand.
He's like,
all right,
here we go.
And he went out there like a fucking stud.
Good for him.
God bless him.
You know what?
Yeah.
He was like,
you know what?
Here's my Dick.
I got a personality and I'm,
and I can bench more than everybody in this room.
While he's like,
you know,
hey man,
I didn't fucking fail Dick School.
That's just where I was born with.
Yeah,
it's all good.
But maybe he would lop it off and get one of these giant ones.
Yeah.
I mean if you could add tissue to your tea
or Wang,
hey,
by the way,
wonderful.
Most guys were clubbing sticks would be like,
oh,
I had another end.
No fucking way.
No dream.
Yeah.
That's some stuff that would be like those crazy girls who have breast implants
that are just an believably ridiculous like basketball sized and they can't,
they want to get them bigger.
That's a lot of guys that there's this,
there's a lot of guys,
and I don't know if it's just the gay community,
but that the dispatch they did,
it was two guys in the gay community who were shooting their dicks with silicone
liquid silicone and sailing too.
They do that and so it created this and the problem was it just created this
amorphous blob that they would stuff into jeans and they'd be like,
check this out.
Sorry about the Dick.
Yeah,
but sorry,
piece lumpy.
Just stretching.
Is Sergio Valenti,
all fucking the outside of it as all pudgy and awe.
Dimpled,
all dimpled like cottage cheese.
Dick,
what's that bump?
I don't know.
Silicon Gone Awry.
Damn silicon.
So unpredictable.
When you think about like I'm predict people have a cellulite on their legs.
Imagine if you've got that on your Dick.
Look if a cellulite Dick,
have you ever had like some of those medical journals?
I sat next to a dermatologist or a plastic surgeon and she was going through her
iPad and she had pictures and I was sitting next door.
She was asking me about acting and I was,
she was showing me the key and some of them,
she was really an,
she was covering the faces of these patients with their hands so I wouldn't see
their faces cause she was that professional.
Even on a plane,
she was trying to protect their privacy or whatever.
I saw this guy had a growth on his body,
on his shoulder,
looked like a,
a shoulder pat of skin of cauliflower.
And I said,
how do you take that off?
And she said,
you don't.
I said,
what do you mean?
She goes,
it's just too full of blood vessels.
He would die.
This is part of his body and he has to have it.
I go,
so what did,
he just leaves a giant flap of cauliflower on his back and shoulder stead.
Yeah.
Unfortunately it's just a deformity.
Wow.
And there's so many,
or you see those medical journals and you're like,
oh boy.
So people,
you know,
don't realize how lucky you are.
I can Canada living in civilization will,
we're in Canada.
We're in the line.
I mean Alaska because our America looks like it's Canada should be Canada.
It's British Columbia.
It's like around the corner where we stole it from Russia.
Right.
The deal.
Probably they can have it back.
No,
fuck.
That place is awesome man.
Alaska good people in the last,
oh well that's one of the things that I realized when I went to anchorage with
Ari when we went fishing.
And then we did some shows up there though.
The bears tooth,
the,
um,
the thing about Alaska is that there's this insane wilderness around them and
there's not a shit ton of people.
So they developed this like different kind of community.
It's like a,
even though anchorage is a real city,
there's like a nice bond.
I think it's because they have to,
they may have to rely
on each other in a real way.
Bears look,
dude,
when we were in anchorage,
there was just that year a fucking kid on campus was killed by a moose.
What?
Whoa.
Well listen,
we met a guy,
Matt.
Uh,
what's his last name?
Um,
Matt.
Which guy?
The Guy who took care of us.
Who?
Matt from Alaska.
Yeah.
Matt from Alaska who drove us to the airport,
sent our bags.
Just did us a solid that most people would never do an La Matt Hamilton,
Matt Hamilton.
You handed them your very expensive,
you know,
stuff.
Yeah.
And he's,
well,
he's a good dude.
You know,
you can,
you,
you get a sense of people like in these communities where they're,
they're just,
it's not like the hustle and bustle of New York City where there's a million
rats all stuck in a maze and everybody's fucking fighting for the last chroma
cheese and jammed up and traffic.
No,
these folks are fishing.
That guy was offering us fucking halibut.
You know,
he wants some how it got some frozen,
how a deer I can run back and get deer.
I mean he caught 160 pound.
How Labatt that said person.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean a halibut's like literally probably almost the size of this desk.
They were sitting there how big?
It's like a giant flounder.
Looks at us.
Flounder on the phone to family.
Yeah.
That's an amazing,
amazing part of the world and the fishing there is just,
the waters are so rich.
Alaska truly is like the last wilderness,
the wilderness.
I love those shows.
Like,
I don't know if you ever watch them but like they had a bunch of Zeros.
Do you watch them?
I haven't watched any of them.
Fucking great man.
Life below zero is the best at all.
Those,
there's Alaska,
the last frontier,
which is pretty good too,
but I caught a little fuckery on that show.
He did.
Yeah.
They're doing some fucking reality TV show bullshit.
Like they had a bear that was there and they were running away from the bear and
um,
they were fishing on this river.
The guy and his wife were fishing on the river and they're like,
we got to get away from this bear.
The bear's eating filleted salmon.
So they baited the bear,
they baited the bear to get there and then they get film.
That's annoying.
The bears eating salmon.
I'm looking at these clean like filet marks where the,
the,
the filets we'll remove from the body,
but the head and the tail,
we're remained.
It wasn't anything that a bear did.
Bear didn't like catch that salmon and eat it there and they didn't catch any
salmon.
So it was just bullshit.
They're just bay.
They were cool.
The bears,
we've got to get out of here.
You can kind of tell whenever they're acting a little bit too.
Yeah,
it's unfortunate.
But that always happens in those God damn shows,
man.
They,
they run out of shit to do,
but they follow up five different people or six different people.
And there's always something that these people are doing because they have to
prepare for like the river rising,
they have to prepare for bears are coming into camp.
They have to prepare for all these different things.
So fascinating stuff.
Nature,
nature.
You know,
it's interesting because if you look at anything in nature,
including human beings,
whether it's,
you know,
an ant or a spider rolling something,
a Web,
whatever it is,
everybody in nature is constantly fighting nature.
It's a
fight.
It just to survive.
You want to survive out there.
You can see why men,
men has always kind of pitted himself against nature.
Just the constant struggle of trying to push yourself into a situation where you
don't have to deal and contend with nature.
We've done a pretty good job of it,
you know,
by by figuring out ways to innovate,
ways to control our environment stuff.
But if you,
if you had to scratch out a living and looking at animals,
I mean you can watch deer who don't move very much cause they have to conserve
energy and they have to stay in one area and they eat and that one area then
they moved down to lower land.
But a lot of times guess what happens that people don't realize with deer they
starve to death.
Oh,
not just,
not sometimes.
Like often,
often it happens all the time.
It's brutal.
Most of these people that are against hunting or the think that like somehow or
another that nature is supposed to be this like peaceful thing.
They don't understand what the reality of the life of these animals is.
Teddy Roosevelt had a great quote on people who don't understand hunting and
people have a problem with it who loved nature and he wrote that death by
violence,
death by cold,
death by starvation.
These are the normal ends of the noble and stately creatures of the Wilderness.
The sentimentalist who prattle about the peaceful life of nature,
the peaceful,
you know,
that's what he wrote.
Peaceful life of nature.
Do not understand.
It's utter mercilessness life is hard and cruel and these,
oh,
okay,
well this is a fucked up speech.
And in what the sentimentalist call a state of nature.
Yeah,
it's in Hobbs said,
it's short,
brutish.
What does the,
what does the x,
the expression,
um,
short and brutish
nature is tough.
Well,
you know what it is,
is it's just indifferent.
That was one of the things that we said when we got to this place where like
when we sat out there and looked out off the top of those mountains and we
looked at all of these,
just feel so insignificant.
Oh no people,
no people.
Enormous,
enormous place.
Not a fucking person to be seen.
And one of the first things we were thinking,
it was like,
it's so indifferent.
It just doesn't give a fuck.
It doesn't give a fuck if you're here or well,
Rinella was saying also that,
you know,
the native Americans that lived there were,
hundreds of years ago,
whatever,
we're stayed on the coast.
They had a lot of shellfish and fished.
They didn't really go into the interior to get deer.
So difficult to do.
I mean,
you know,
especially before they had firearms,
it was very,
I mean,
imagine,
you want to shoot an animal with a bow and Arrow,
especially in old school bone Arrow,
you must get inside of 30 yards,
40 yards,
you're fucking really pushing it,
man.
Even with a compound bow,
a 40 yard shot is very difficult to be accurate with.
And those old bows,
like a lot of them just didn't have the amount of power
to pull.
Like the Mongols had these crazy fucking bows,
but they required like 160 pounds of pole.
Like you could probably shoot at a reliable 50 60 yard distance with those if
you got really good at it.
But you're fucking practicing with those goddamn things every day.
Sure.
If you have a spear,
get the fuck Outta here.
How far can you throw a spear?
Can you even throw a spear?
10 yards?
I mean,
how far can you reliably throw a spear,
especially to make it then 10 throw it accurately and hit an animal and kill it
or graze it and it's gonna run off and go nowhere near you.
So they,
they,
they hung around where the water was because shellfish and netting,
you can net fish and there was a more reliable way to capture me.
Will you,
when they,
when who was taught to tell a story about how the Inuits would bend a bone,
they'd bend a bone and they would cover it in fat.
Yes.
And then the,
and it would be frozen fat and then the polar bear would come eat the bone and
the bone would open,
expand in the,
in a polar bear stomach or throat.
And suddenly it would basically take three days to die and they would follow it
until it died and then take just for the coat because they,
that's how they kept warm.
Well,
one of the ways he used to kill wolves would,
they would take an a knife,
like a razor sharp knife and they want embedded into the ground and put blood on
the knife.
So the wolves would come along and lick the knife and cut their tongue open and
bleed to death.
And because they keep,
well,
they would keep licking and cleaning and licking and bleeding.
They would taste the blood.
Yeah.
And then they would just die.
They're fucking dumb.
Cunt wolves kind of genius.
That's pretty brilliant.
Well,
you know,
people are ingenious when they have to stay alive and we obviously didn't have
to stay alive.
We had meals,
we had food,
we had,
you know,
we brought apple and protein bars and all kinds of shit and planning though
plenty of blood.
Think about if we had to live off the land while we were there.
What the fuck did we found?
We found a couple salamanders.
We saw a duck,
six or seven blueberries.
Yeah.
There was these blueberries.
There was microscopic,
the height of it,
like a head of a match,
blueberries and they tasted like powder.
It tastes like nothing.
Good luck surviving.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I eat a handful of them and one of them was kind of sweet,
but like you go to whole foods,
you get this fucking choosy GMO blue birds.
I know where they came from.
They who cares.
Tennis ball sized bike down on them and blow up in your mouth and even then
you're like,
I need more food.
You know,
and death by violence.
Death by cold death by starvation.
Teddy Roosevelt was a bad motherfucker.
Yup.
The normal ends,
wasn't it?
Teddy Roosevelt who designated the Yellowstone park is a national park.
I don't know.
And Yosemite I believe.
Did he?
Yup.
Smart man.
Yes he was.
That's a good place for national park.
That's an unbelievably beautiful place.
It's going to kill everybody eventually with the Super Volcano.
I've been thinking about nothing else since you told me about that.
Terrifying.
That's the Black Swan.
As they say,
that's like everybody's going about their life and all of a sudden,
guess what?
There's a supervolcano that could eradicate life on earth.
Well not just one.
There's six of them worldwide and two of them are in California,
which really crazy.
Got Basically big zits on the earth.
Yeah,
there's,
there's supervolcanoes everywhere.
There's super volcanoes all over the world and there's not just one in
Yellowstone,
there's a,
there's a gigantic super volcano.
I think we said an Indonesia that they think is responsible for the reason why
there is only,
you know,
they believe that 75,000 years ago this super volcano in Indonesia exploded and
when it exploded,
they think that that's why all human beings have some sort of a,
a relationship to each other.
That we all came from an original group of human beings 74,000 years ago.
Toba,
it's a,
it's a Caldera volcano in Sumatra.
It's ready for this hold onto your Dick.
1080 square miles.
So people are living on top of it as we speak.
The will that I don't think they,
I don't know if they are not,
but it's in,
it's in India.
It's in Sumatra,
Indonesia,
and it's the only super volcano in existence that can be described as
Yellowstone's big sister.
74,000 years ago.
Toba erupted and objected several thousand times more material than erupted from
Mount Saint Helens in 1980 several thousand times more.
Some researchers think that Toba is ancient super eruption and the global cold
spell it triggered might explain a mystery in the human genome.
Our genes suggest that we all come from a few thousand people just tens of
thousands of years ago instead of from a much older,
bigger lineage as fossil evidence testifies.
So we have the fossil evidence,
which shows them a much older ProMag broader lineage.
But the people of today all come from a few thousand people.
That might've been the only fucking human beings that survived.
It's Goddamn supervolcano 74,000 so that's why they can trace like a hot,
like a Hasidic Jews in Finland or in Africans.
Yeah.
To Africans.
That's unbelievable.
And that's all 74,000 years ago,
man.
So,
so,
so then the,
but we do find with the genome that some people have some cro-magnon genes and I
think,
well we are cro magnon I think you're thinking of neanderthal nine.
I mean,
yeah,
well there's,
there's,
I think there's obviously I'm an idiot.
Don't listen to me Google this,
but,
um,
I think there's debate on this because I think that some believe that these
genomes are from a common ancestor and that I think there's debate as to whether
or not people fuck neanderthals or neanderthals fuck people.
We interbred like I've joked around about it that my,
I'm pretty sure someone in my past fucked a monkey.
Like when people were like,
just starting to not be monkeys anymore.
Somebody's sex of all,
you've got long lines.
Somebody let me just one more time.
One more time soon to get back in there and somehow the monkey got pregnant and
like what the fuck?
And then that's where my line came from,
but semi and jeans.
But I think that,
um,
there's debate as to whether or not humans interbred
with neanderthals and that's why or whether or not we have a common ancestor.
I don't think it's been completely figured out yet,
but if neanderthals were around for sure somebody would fuck one.
Yeah.
People thought these pick one person.
I've seen people fuck chicken.
That's it.
My buddy was a cop.
He found a guy fucking a chicken in a car.
There was a family man and he had a chicken under a fucking towel and he goes,
what are you doing?
You guys love thing?
First of all,
I love that expression.
Family man.
He's a family man.
He's a family man in San Francisco.
He's fucking his chicken under a towel.
Excuse me,
sir.
Is that illegal?
I think it is illegal.
Like they can arrest you for cruelty to animals or something.
But then again you eat chicken.
I don't know.
Yeah.
It's not weird that they had to make,
it's like public indecency.
I think they get you on stuff like that.
But you were fucking a chicken.
Although,
how about this?
That's a very good question because yes,
your honor.
I fucked the chicken under a towel.
It's my thing free country,
you kill an eat chickens so I don't know.
And by,
and I should be able to fuck the chicken then kill and eat it.
Technically kill it and then fuck it.
But that's like you're,
you're a Weirdo.
Yeah.
Kill it and then fuck it.
You're like some sort of more feeling.
I wonder if that's a law though.
I have to joke about it.
You heard the joke?
No.
Well it's a bit about you could you,
you can kill an animal but you know a lot of fuck it.
But we can do is take like a meal size portion and use it to jerk off with it.
Like someone came into your house,
you jerk it off with a chicken cutlet.
Be like,
what the fuck?
I can't have my privacy.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like,
like chicken.
But if as long as it's like no one would stop you like look,
look,
okay,
a fleshlight,
what's a fleshlight fleshlight it's something that resembles fleshed.
It's made out of like some sort of a rubber,
whatever,
a proxy.
I don't know.
What the fuck is it made out of polymer.
You're,
you're putting your penis in that because it feels like flesh,
right?
Well you see how green would it be to take an actual chicken cutlet used to jerk
off with warming up in a microwave so it feels like flesh or you let it sit at
room temperature,
whatever.
You jerk off with it and then you cook it and eat it.
Yeah,
that's like you're making best use of all the materials.
But that would be probably,
they couldn't do anything to you,
but if you fucked a chicken they could probably do something to you.
Well,
Jonathan Haidt,
who is a guy who studies this,
he wrote a book called the happiness hypothesis talks exactly about this
example.
He said,
if you masturbate it,
if you,
if you took a dead chicken and you ate it very,
it'd be fine.
If you took the dead chicken fucked it,
came in it and then ate it.
People will be like,
oh yeah,
and he's another really difficult,
if you didn't come,
what if you like a tantric guy?
A good,
good question.
You're likely question,
put your penis and you're like,
nope.
That's how I fucked chickens.
That's,
I don't,
I draw the line and actually coming in them,
you could come on this.
You just get that tight knit.
That's the weakest muscle I have.
Everything else is really strong that hold back calm muscles gotten better as
I've,
it's like an old lady's underarm,
you know,
old ladies,
they're underneath your arm,
just fucking dangles this,
there's no power to it.
It's got no strength.
Old Ladies can't do dips.
Put Out,
come muscle,
put like a weight belt on an old lady and Toda do dips.
That's like how strong my come muscle breaks and just go home.
It's basically curtains.
Yeah.
It doesn't have any power than hate.
Talks about talks about fucking like that.
He used that example.
Then he used another example where he says,
if a brother and sister in the woods use protection and have sex,
it's the same idea.
We immediately go,
oh,
that's wrong.
Oh.
But he says,
okay,
it's wrong.
It is.
That's taboo in most cultures.
But again,
and I haven't kids,
they had sex and nobody's getting hurt.
They're both,
you know,
they go on with their lives.
What does that,
why do we have this revolt and it where we have this Builtin,
we as a society and as people universally have these very interesting through
lines in culture,
one being that all cultures recognize all cultures no matter primitive,
recognize a humorous insults.
Uh,
every culture had no matter how primitive has a form of humorous in salts for
each other.
They make fun of each other.
Uh,
the other is that every culture,
every according to Steven Pinker,
every culture they've ever studied,
100%.
It has,
has a place for humorous insult.
So making fun,
ribbing each other.
Right?
Uh,
and,
and you're talking about the most primitive tribes are the most aboriginal
tribes and the most,
you know,
most technically technologically advanced tribes all have always had some form
of humorous and salt.
The other is a recognition for certain things that are taboo.
Yes.
But the different across the board culturally,
like we were talking about those cultures in New Guinea and warriors in New
Guinea that have this crazy thing where they molest young boy,
you know,
strangling where they wear the were widows,
a woman's husband dies the next man closest to the husband strangles her.
Yeah.
But those are very,
very isolated tribes that have had not shared any ideas with other people that
had no cross pollination.
So you're going to get very weird fetishistic sort of,
um,
examples of human behavior.
And that also like when you,
we know that like when people molest children,
that those children who have been molested often have this very distorted idea
of sexuality and sometimes become abusers themselves.
And that this could have easily happened on the small island 100%.
But these are large groups of people,
like thousands of people practice these,
these new Guinea semen warrior rituals.
It's still very small in relation.
People need to read about this cause I mean,
we're not going into depth about it.
I mean,
it's an incredible fucking bizarre thing.
These new Guinea warriors,
they take these young boys away from their mother at a very early age and they
start having sex with them and they do it because they say that the boy semen in
order to grow up strong and healthy by ingesting seaman either through their
mouth or through their butt and like this is how they grow up.
I mean this is the,
the semen warriors of New Guinea,
Google it and freak the fuck out.
Jared diamond did so many examples that has so many crazy examples of insane
human behavior.
It's usually probably some lone pervert who's like,
let's fuck boys.
And now like he's the leader but,
but you know,
they've got,
that's why they have cannibalism and all kinds of stuff.
But whenever you see a large population,
a civilization of people who have been able to cross pollinate ideas.
So if you take huge areas,
the bounty belt of Africa,
the Fertile Crescent of the North Africa and the Middle East,
China for example,
that's where taboos have strong sexual undercurrents,
where certain sexual activity and a lot of times has said is very taboo.
And there's a lot of similarities you can draw with that.
Um,
which is interesting.
So,
so there are through lines you can draw with cultures.
You do get those aberrations with those smaller groups of people that just
isolated people.
Timing about the new Guinea people when we're on our trip about eating their
dead bodies and the way they would,
oh my plane is insane fucking thing that they should do.
Yeah.
Well I still do.
I had Jared diamond on the podcast and I said,
tell me about,
you've seen them cannibalize and he said,
you really want to know about it.
And I said,
yeah.
I said,
well you asked for it.
And he said some tribes when they would have warring,
they'd have a war and they killed somebody.
They would eat,
they'd cook the pop up and chopping up,
Cook,
Cook the body.
But there are tribes in Papa New Guinea that will take the body.
Like if a relative dies,
they'll take the body,
they'll lay it out naked on slats of wood.
So there are slats and their holes and they put buckets under the slats and they
let the body just purify and Gel to the point where it starts to drip into the
buckets.
And then they take their sweet potatoes and they dip their sweet potatoes into
the human goo and they eat it.
And,
and Oh and here's the other problem.
They are the reason a lot of,
and they'd life expectancy for most of them in the highlands was like 40 years
old.
Uh,
most died by violent violent deaths from interwar and from infection and things.
But they would also,
when they would do that,
they would get a,
what they called laughing disease cocoon you,
which is a crude spelled Jacob's crudes fell.
What does that mad cow disease essentially from eating,
you know,
brain and you know all that tissue.
So don't eat people.
Guys.
Don't let the buy Gel and future via at least cook and eat a filet.
If you're going to eat somebody eat the chest the ass.
In Joe Rogan's case,
he's got a set of cheeks on him and you've got some big legs.
I was looking at your legs.
I think you're like,
is it actually gotten bigger?
You had your,
you had your pants off for a second near the campfire ton and try your ass out.
As we were talking goes literally doing squats,
hanging his wet ass over the fire and I was like,
I was like looking at your legs.
I was like,
the kids got some,
he's got,
he's got a strong lower body.
It looks like a a Centaur.
Well I told you I did prepare for this.
Yeah,
I'm pulling it
out for two.
Why didn't you tell me to prepare?
Because you wouldn't listen.
I would listen.
I work out.
I've been lifting heavier out.
Shut up.
I do not look at my body.
I was,
I was doing a lot of a kettle bell squats,
taking two seventies clean him,
get him in here and just show that 25 okay.
I could do that.
That's a lot of ways you were making that noise.
You gotta get a breathe out.
You guys.
I love when guys,
I love them guys described their body bro.
When I was living dude,
my chest was like,
am I as like Bro,
my legs NASCAR like
isn't it amazing what of calming and like like morale boosting thing.
Having a fire was for us.
God,
we couldn't build a fire for the first what,
three days and when we finally got that fire going it was me and Mike.
We led the charge.
This idea,
I was like we're going to make a fucking fire.
Like we have gasoline,
we have whiskey.
Tell him how I tell them what the best kindling is in the world.
Fritos.
Fritos,
Light on fire like a motherfucker and hold your flame.
Hold their flank candles that you can't blow out on a birthday cake.
While we were in town where we were in camp,
I watched the documentary,
King Corn.
I had it on my laptop is one of the days where we couldn't go anywhere.
I just sat and watched this.
I was worried that my laptop was going to cook and explode cause it was like in
a sea of dew.
But my laptop is tough cause it's been spilled on so many times.
I spilled coffee on it.
It's tough and my laptop.
But this fucking documentary is an amazing document.
It King Corn,
if you've never seen it,
you,
if you're interested at all and like what the fuck is going on with corn and how
money things corn is in in our country.
You got to watch his documentary.
These guys did an amazing job.
These two guys,
they got out of college,
they were doing some research on corn and they decided to uh,
get their,
their hair and their tissue,
uh,
analyzed.
And when they analyze it,
this guy said,
the carbon in your body is all from corn.
We adjust somebody that you may,
you eat so much corn that your body's made out of corn.
It's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
So these guys,
they rented or leased a an acre of land on this guy's property in Iowa and they
grew their own corn and grew it from the time it went to the ground to adding
pesticides,
to taking it to market.
They went through the whole thing and then explained all the different things
that corn is in.
And it is fucking stunning.
It's in everything,
right?
It's also stunning how all of it is with subsidies.
And if it wasn't for government subsidies,
all these people would lose money.
These guys got a check from the government to grow.
Their acre of corn was small check because it was only one acre.
But if they're growing 10,000,
30,000 acres,
like a lot of these folks are,
they,
they rely on these government cheque ethanol,
ethanol,
which we don't really need any more.
But ethanol is used and now there's a lobbying f there's a very strong lobbying
presence in Washington that's not going to let ethanol go away.
Athan all has a cottage industry around it.
People make money off of growing corn for fuel.
Uh,
and,
and there are a thousand examples of that.
You know,
we're,
corn has a very strong lobby.
The sugar lobby is very strong as another documentary called,
fed up about,
you know,
when,
when the World Health Organization came along and said,
10 only 10% of your diet should be sugar.
And a of all kinds,
whether it's fruit juice or just sugar,
it's just not good for your body.
We have the science to prove it.
And the the sugar industry and the corn syrup industry came along and said,
well,
if you want your,
you know,
put a lot of pressure on the Bush administration to tell them to World Health
Organization.
If you want your $450 million this year,
you better at Revi.
You better leave that out of your report because we have people believing in our
school lunch programs and stuff to 25% of your diet can be simple sugars.
And you know,
I,
I got to watch that documentary cause it's amazing how slow,
how many interests,
powerful interests get involved in getting you to eat corn,
getting you to eat foods that in their byproducts that,
that they make a lot of money off that may not be so good for your body.
Yeah,
it's,
it's bizarre.
It's bizarre how bad it is for your body and how much of it is in foods,
corn syrup,
corn starch,
corn proteins,
corn,
this corn that it's,
it's incredible.
These corn additives.
And without the subsidies it wouldn't be happening.
It's like our government is literally paying to keep our diets shitty.
Yes sir.
Because they're in bed with this industry and I'm really wondering what would
happen if hemp became legal worldwide and especially legal in the United States
because we sell hemp food.
We sell those hemp protein bars that I brought with us on,
on the trips,
those on it,
uh,
hemp force protein bars and on at hemp force powder.
But we have to buy our hemp from Canada and there's a bunch of different grades
we buy.
The highest grade stuff is very expensive.
And one of the reason why it's very expensive,
it's hard to grow and it's growing up in Canada.
Well,
it's hard to grow in America.
It's impossible to grow.
I should have said it's nice not subsidized either.
No,
it's not substance.
You have to get it in Canada and the,
the,
the hearts,
the hemp hearts that the best part of it is what we get.
And it's,
you know,
it's very high in protein,
but we get that could be all over this country and far and it's easy to fucking
grow it.
It's not susceptible to various bugs and and and bullshit and weeds.
It is a fucking weed.
It grows crazy easy.
Is hemp is hemp a it's in the marijuana family,
right?
This is what it is.
It's the male version of the plant.
The female version of the plant,
yes.
Is where you get the THC but they can grow like acres and acres of non
psychoactive hemp,
like you don't even get,
you know what I mean?
Test positive for THC.
If you eat hemp protein,
but if you eat poppy seed bagels,
you test positive for heroin.
Wow.
People that are going through drug tests,
like if you don't touch poppy seeds,
we can't.
They tell you don't need poppy seeds for x amount of days,
dam because if you eat it,
you'll you turn up positive for heroin.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
It's really crazy.
And hemp is,
it has all the essential amino acids.
It's a far better source of paper.
It's far better.
Building material.
If you ever seen a hemp stalk your pickup,
like a hemp stalk,
like hemp stalk.
Okay.
You can make rope out of it.
I know that will,
yeah.
Will you make the best rope?
Okay.
The best robe in the world parachutes.
George senior,
George Herbert Walker Bush,
the parachute that he use to safely parachute in World War II.
That was made out of hemp that he parachuted to safety with a fucking hemp
parachute.
Wow.
There was a video called hemp for victory were in World War II.
They were incurred.
This is post illegalization by the way,
they made it illegal in the 1930s,
well,
the 1940s,
they were encouraging farmers to grow hemp for the war effort.
Like go pull up heavily then pull up the youtube,
the youtube video hemp for victory.
It was part of it.
Dupont was in cahoots allegedly with William Randolph Hearst,
but William Randolph Hearst was the main reason why hamp became illegal and a
lot of it was because he was going to have to convert all of his paper mills to,
uh,
to hemp paper.
Hemp paper is way better.
Like if you pick up regular paper looking into this hemp for victory,
play this,
I'll play it.
Play the volume.
This was,
this is a propaganda film that they made in the 1940s to get people to start
growing hemp for the war effort.
Wow.
Yeah.
This is fucking crazy.
When you think about it.
This shit is illegal today.
That's amazing.
Look at the,
and those buildings are made of hemp,
you guys,
Rican temples,
when you was already old and the service of mankind
for thousands of years.
Even then this plant had been grown for code engine,
coarse cloth and China and elsewhere in the east for centuries prior to about 18
fifth day,
all the ships that sail the western is my rig with hempen rope and sales for the
sailor and no less than the hangman.
Him was indispensable.
Do you know?
Canvas comes from the word cannabis canvas cloth,
like canvas sales.
Those were all made out of hemp.
I just loved their voices.
They where they talked about things were very formal.
That was their version of the Strip club Dj.
That's right.
Hemp was something that always the music behind with some flute.
Look at that.
Those are hemp courts.
He's good American and by Hamp,
even people in the east,
China and other way other places.
So what happened was in the 1930s they came out with this invention called a
decorticator and the decorticator,
they used it to more effectively processed the hemp fiber would they?
Before they used slavery,
slavery was the only word.
The way they would do it smashed these fibers down and it wasn't as effective as
cotton.
And so they came up with a cotton mill.
When a Eli Whitney came up with the cotton will mill cotton gin.
When they started doing that,
like well cotton's way easier now.
So they started making things out of cotton,
but then they came out with the decorticate in like,
oh shit,
hemp is going to be making a comeback.
And they were hemp is a new billion dollar
crop.
Like pull up the Po,
the cover of Popular Science magazine and a 1930 I want to say 35 37 when I was
on the cover of popular science magazine,
said hemp,
the new billion dollar crop.
This is the cover of this magazine.
And,
and then right after that it was made illegal.
And then dupont and those that aren't just came along just pull up hemp,
the new billion dollar Kraeutler that fucking magazine.
Wow.
1938 there it is.
Hemp.
I always going to buy him clothes and hemp paper and hemp this and hemp food and
hemp oils.
Hemp oils are super good for your body and not psychoactive at all.
When you,
when you said Eli Whitney,
it was the same kind of thing.
I was thinking about how one man's invention made slavery essentially it was a
real abolition movement.
The abolitionist movement going on,
we're slavery was really,
the antislavery movement was gaining tremendous ground cause it was really hard
to justify of course.
And then when Eli Whitney came along with the cotton gin and all the southern
plantations were like,
we got all this free labor and,
and this is white gold.
We're selling the stuff not only to Europe,
to North Africa,
everywhere.
Everybody wants American cotton.
Ah,
not so fast.
We're not getting rid of slavery here.
This makes no sense.
So we got a lot of free labor and uh,
thank you Eli Whitney for,
you know,
I wonder,
I always wonder,
like you come up with this amazing invention and uh,
but that's going to keep up people and slave for about another hundred years.
Thank you very much.
It's just the one of those weird things in history where you just go,
fuck.
Well,
it played a part obviously.
Um,
have you ever heard about this incredible historical story about Morse Morse
code was invented?
No,
this is so amazing.
Was Amazing Shit.
But the,
this is what's more amazing.
Morse was a paint or a very successful oil painter,
very successful.
And his wife,
he got to tell him he got up before Morse code this.
It's very important to remember that the only way to get a message to somebody
throughout history,
w Alexander the Great and George Washington had to use the exact same
methodology,
which was horse,
boat or foot as I messenger pigeon pigeon,
but in very small areas.
What about crow?
Uh,
no,
I'm French and Raven.
I'm afraid.
And I was a raven.
That's in game of Thrones.
That's a lie.
It's a lie,
but no,
no,
no.
They send a raven.
I'm sorry my friend.
That's a lie.
It's go to be in school to be a,
a messenger between anything.
You'll tell me the dragons aren't real.
Uh,
well,
have you ever seen a dragon?
The Crocodile?
Yes,
but crocodiles.
That's true.
That's what happened.
Don't give it away as the mother of dragons.
That's an amazing,
I love that.
I can't wait till that goes back.
She's wonderful.
She's the mother of dragons cause he's a good kid because he see,
hey,
she's a queen,
Bro.
Whatever.
Hey,
don't always is getting all grab.
That's it.
That's my friend Jimmy from back home.
Jimmy to [inaudible] used to say that whenever a girl was like really perverted.
So New York,
Boston,
he would go,
what a good kid.
Good kid.
She's a good kid.
She can park.
Does that cheapen Berkey?
Started saying that she's a good kid.
He's his head too.
Well,
yeah,
it's very New York.
Oh,
so it's an east coast guy.
So for perverts.
Yeah.
Well I don't think,
uh,
you know,
a friend Jimmy was all Boston kid.
You list,
you say it's grant was the one who turned yellow stone into a national park.
Um,
Theodore Roosevelt turned Yosemite so more to Dj Jackpot.
Dj Morse Morse gets a message.
Your wife is sick in Connecticut.
He lives in the north,
northern New York or something.
He gets on a horse and buggy and he goes down and by the time he gets there,
he loved his wife.
She wasn't only dead,
she had been buried.
So we never got a chance to say bye to her.
He's heartbroken.
And all he does as this painter,
a painter,
is he obsesses over how in the world he can figure out,
he could figure out a way to not have that,
where you could get,
if he had gotten the message earlier,
he could have gotten there to see his wife.
Seven years later he's on an ocean liner and he meets a dude who's a scientist,
is working with electromagnetic fields and he basically says,
do you think it would be possible to use this electromagnetic field and get it
somewhere else so that we can quick and time.
Long story short,
he could,
he,
he basically gets together with this,
this guy who is a scientist and electromatic name fields.
They send a message,
and I can't remember whether it was from New York to Washington DC,
but I think it was a,
but at first it was a short distance.
It was only like,
you know,
uh,
I don't know,
a quarter mile or something.
I don't know.
What are you looking it up right now in the Baltimore,
Washington and Baltimore.
And they sent a message in as much time as it takes electricity to get there.
It was instantaneous and it,
it,
it was of course,
a bigger revolution than even the Internet.
Some would argue because before that time and throughout all of human history,
the only way to get a message to somebody was by foot,
boat or horse,
and it just had never been done before.
It was a complete revolution and it started because the guy was heartbroken over
not being able to say goodbye to his wife before she died.
That's incredible.
That is fucking incredible.
That's Morse code.
That's why I love history.
Well,
it's fascinating.
We think that there was people a long time ago that if something was going on 10
miles away,
there's no way of finding out.
I know.
No Way.
I know now.
If so,
there's a revolution going on in China right now in Hong Kong.
We were watching it live and real time,
there's streaming websites,
you know,
there's,
there's criticism of the way China's handling and you get to read various
different points of view.
I mean it's an oppressive,
oppressive regimes aren't allowed to get away with murder.
They can,
but they have to be very careful because they know the world's watching it.
It makes the world less brutal.
I would argue.
Oh way more.
Way,
way more accountable.
[inaudible] would have done if the Mongols were coming into the Middle East and
just killing people wholesale on Russia
the way they did.
Think about what the world we'd be doing.
We'd be like,
well we've got to stop these assholes on horseback right now.
You know,
but nobody was watching.
We didn't know.
That's where you got to love something called Merck.
Okay.
Cause we just send some drones over there.
Oh you got 160 pound bow and you like to drink horseman blood mixed with
Marriage Mountain Nevada sipping coffee,
Xbox,
drinking mountain dew and a fucking kid with a hemorrhoid is lightened.
You bitches up from the sky.
Big Thumb muscles.
Could you imagine if you could do that?
I mean if time travel becomes reality where you can't mess up the timeline like
safe,
all timelines are completely independent and say if you could go back in time
and you could have like have at it and do whatever the fuck you want,
who would have no bearing on the future if they find out the timelines are
completely independent and that if you do go back in time and has literally no
effect on the current future,
you go back to where you were and nothing's changed you even your,
your actual actions never really took place.
They took place in an alternative timeline,
how much would you love to fucking suit up with some like navy seal type
bulletproof armor?
Lock yourself down in a fucking giant tank and go roll into the Mongol Empire.
One person.
So you know what?
I win fit.
I'm just taking over.
I think about that every single day and I'm not kidding.
I think about a helicopter gunship while these a holes on their horses coming in
and try to kill and rape and do all that and be like,
Hey,
guess what?
Check out this birth from the sky.
I looked like a giant horn.
It tell me if this stinks.
Kick,
kick,
kick.
Now think about this.
What will people from a thousand years from now be thinking about us and how
ridiculous where they think that we are listening with these assholes did.
They made explosions in little metal containers and these explosions propelled
these very dense metal balls through the air.
I ridiculous speeds and they went through each other's bodies and that's how
they did war.
They couldn't read minds.
They didn't understand it's enlightenment and they were also human,
didn't have pills yet.
They didn't know how to have perfect genetics.
They didn't know how to engineer cancer away.
They were all fighting over resources.
They got called.
They had electricity that was coming from wait for it.
Nuclear Power,
these fucking idiots.
They had developed these nuclear sites where they had these generators that they
could never shut off and they kept them running and when they would have
anything would go wrong and the power would go out.
It would melt down and they would have to clear everyone out of the area for
$100,000 that you had to be tied to a power source.
You literally had to have a long rope coming out of your head that was attached
to some huge box just to hear yourself or other people.
Everything was plugged in.
Well,
how about solar power in California?
Why isn't everything solar powered?
I don't know.
We don't have any fucking rain.
I mean,
he's,
the one resource that we have that's bountiful and plentiful is sunlight.
We have a real problem.
We've,
it's rained once in a year here.
It's crazy.
We have a real problem,
but we have massive,
massive amounts of solar electricity that no one's tapping into and we've got to
fucking ocean that we could just desalinate.
Why don't,
why haven't they figured out how to do that and say,
well,
it takes an incredible amount of power.
What did I fucking solar power.
How about use solar power?
Figure out an efficient way of using solar power to process the salt out of the
water.
And we have the most green,
lush landscape ever.
I California,
we have the technology yet.
I think that's really hard to do that get tow work on it.
A guy named Morris figured out a way to send signals back with no Internet on
inventors.
Note with even have cars.
No,
no cars.
no.
Do they have phones?
They had trains.
They,
I think they had the internal [inaudible] worked on coal.
If you had a book and you spit on the pages,
all the fucking information would run down and leak.
Uh,
think about it.
I,
we're full of books.
Had to be a hand handwoven and,
but the printing press was another revolution.
I mean Gutenberg's but he was a watchmaker and it was just the printing press
was another,
when you talk about the seminar people in history,
that people that changed everything.
He's in there.
When was the printing press invented?
I used to know the answer to this,
uh,
in the,
it might've been actually in the beginning of the 18 hundreds or maybe even
earlier than that.
Let me like,
I think 17 it was like the 17 the actual printing press was probably invented,
I believe in 17 why?
Why ask why Jamie?
I'm just trying to guess because I can't remember.
I guess if by the time it actually took hold,
it was a while.
It was about a hundred years.
It's amazing to think that back before then,
like people had to write out all the letters.
Yeah,
I think it's 1600 1640 if you get like an old book,
it was earlier in 1640 well,
Martin Luther,
what didn't,
wasn't that one of the reasons why Martin Luther was able to spread his
propaganda so fast because he was printing things and putting them on the walls
of church.
He didn't know he,
he,
he did his,
I think it was bitten Berg.
He did.
He did his hundred proclamations,
any nail it to the church door.
And that was basically saying that the Catholic church was a sham,
or at least they didn't need all this money and it was corrupt.
And if you want the word of God,
all you need is the Bible.
You don't need all this elaborate.
It was actually more than that.
He actually phonetically translated the Bible for the first time for the common
folk.
Regular people could read the Bible.
I that wasn't actually Martin Luther's,
that wasn't Martin Luther's contribution.
Martin Luther's contribution was to say he was a Jesuit priest,
I believe,
who said that it to be,
um,
you can be just as holy as the pope,
as a common man.
If you are religious and you follow the Bible,
you don't need this huge infrastructure on hierarchy of bishops and priests.
He did something with translating the Bible.
I know this for sure.
What was,
um,
what does it,
what year was it?
Wow.
50.
That's incredible.
But it didn't really take hold.
The printing press wasn't used,
uh,
you know,
until a hundred,
200 years later.
I mean,
I was on a wide scale.
The projects,
yeah,
Mar the Luther Bible,
it German language Bible translation from the Hebrew and ancient Greek by Martin
Luther.
Yeah,
it was a,
so the new testament was first published in 1522 and the complete Bible
containing the old and new testaments,
uh,
was 1534 and the project absorbed Luther's later years,
thanks to then recently invented printing press.
The result was a widely disseminated and,
uh,
contributed significantly to development of today's modern high German language.
And so what had happened was when Luther,
this is all from,
there's a,
um,
the reason why I know it is because of a Dan Carlin's hardcore history podcast
of on it.
Um,
I don't remember the exact episode.
I'll,
I'll try to recall it,
but it's amazing this episode on Martin Luther and how the Luther had created
this movement and this movement had actually gone far and beyond his ideas and
gotten right completely,
totally radical,
which was essentially the proletariat can be just as holy as somebody with cloth
and a crown.
I mean,
in other words,
you,
you was,
it was kind of a,
it was kind of the democratization of Christianity,
right?
I mean,
all you need was a bible and to walk and to live the word of God and you could
be,
you need a church in order to,
that was,
that was real heresy to say that,
you know,
you as a farmer,
if you follow the word of God,
can be even less corrupt,
envy in more favor with God than even the pope.
That was,
that was pretty radical.
I mean,
he,
I think he had to leave Germany for it.
Well,
I don't,
I don't remember exactly specifically what the events were,
but his,
his take on it,
Dan Carlin's take on it.
I think your God damn it,
I'm going to find it here,
but just didn't,
didn't his teaching sparked a hundred years war.
I mean,
the Catholics and the process is vicious wars.
Thor's angels is the name of the podcast.
Um,
you gotta you gotta listen to it because it is fucking absolutely,
completely stunning.
It,
uh,
he's a,
he's a fucking amazing guy,
man.
Dan Carlin,
his podcasts are amazing.
And his,
uh,
his,
his take on it is so,
it's so enthralling.
He's so good at like being theatrical and dragging you into an explaining it,
all that.
But he explains all the personalities that were involved and all the conflicts
that were involved.
But it was essentially the first time where the public had gotten a hold of what
it really said in the Bible because before you couldn't read the Bible,
you had to,
yeah,
it was ready to eat.
So they had to rely on other people and it was red a lot of times in Latin and,
and a lot of people didn't speak Latin.
They would just go to church and listen to the,
you know,
listen to the priest speaks to this day is all summer long island.
You go to the pub,
you go to church resell,
so we'll give you,
you would do things for the priest and they would,
they would grant you,
um,
one of the war,
what Kimber the word for it,
but you'd basically get points in favor of going to heaven.
Let's go.
It became very,
very like,
you know,
you still liquid one was hand written.
Amazing.
Oh,
how about that?
What Steven Elvis sang about all the buffalo?
Yeah.
Well Dan Flores,
um,
buffalo diplomacy and bison diplomacy.
He's uh,
the Chi.
I'm going to try to get him on the podcast.
I'm getting his information from a vanilla,
but what essentially is saying is that our idea is that the white man came and
killed all the buffalo.
There were millions of Buffalo.
And then also the,
there's a commonly held misconception that people gave smallpox to the native
Americans on purpose.
And that would really happened was smallpox.
They didn't even know what the fuck smallpox was.
And the French had given it to the native Americans accidentally because they
had it,
it spread through the native American,
the Spanish too,
I think.
Yes.
And killed a huge amount of people.
They say 90% of the population,
90% of the people.
So when that happened,
the buffalo just grew out of control.
And what he talked about is how the early settlers,
the early Europeans,
they documented all these different things that they seen.
They had seen all deer,
elk,
all the different animals.
Let's see,
they didn't talk about Buffalo.
They did.
They didn't document it.
But then hundreds of years later after the native American population has
dwindled,
substantially,
90% of them have died off because of smallpox.
The buffalo were out of fucking control.
And he also talked about how the introduction of the horse changed the way they
were hunting because the horse,
the horse even proceeded a lot of European settlers,
Spanish,
they brought the horse over during the Cortez days.
Yes.
And that's why Cortez had no idea.
They thought that's what spread influenza through the Mississippi Delta and all
those different diseases that,
that native Americans had never been exposed to.
Because when they came back they saw these towns that were empty and yet it was
like,
where are all the people?
Well they died off.
And what Dan Flores apparently saying,
I'm going to try to get him on soon,
is that the native Americans just with the horse and the firearm were on their
way to eradicating the buffalo or extra painting.
Meaning,
you know,
instinctually local local extinctions and that,
cause they stopped farming,
right?
They would,
they would,
they would follow the Buffalo.
Yeah,
exactly.
because they're fucking 2000 pound animal that just stand still.
I mean,
yeah.
And they had guns and they were on horses so they could ride as fast as the
buffalo could run it up to them.
It's delicious.
And it's like shooting a house.
So they,
what had happened was when the western people came and killed like millions of
buffaloes and stack them on top of each other.
And the reason why there were so many buffalo in the first place is they had
gotten wildly out of control,
wildly out of control because so many native Americans have died really.
I mean,
we're doing,
while we're doing a really bad job of explaining this,
but apparently this guy,
Dan Flores has some really interesting information and a deep,
deep base of knowledge on this and this subject and all sorts of historical
points of reference reference that he can point to that explains why these
animals had died off and what was going on.
But it's,
it's amazing when you think that this country,
like you're talking about the,
the very earliest European settlers,
1,415 hundreds,
that's nothing.
It's not,
it's a blink of an eye.
It's 500 years ago.
I also think it's
patronize him to suggest that the native Americans weren't exactly like white
people and a lot of ways in terms of just they,
they would,
they of course,
they would hunt things to expert to a patient.
I mean,
uh,
just this human beings let go,
going to go in that kind of rugged terrain.
You're going to,
you're going to follow buffalo if it's that easy and if you kill them,
you'll go to the next heart.
Come on.
But I also do think that the way they were living by taking everything from this
animal and utilizing every piece of the animal,
utilizing the bones,
utilize it without a doubt.
Yeah.
And they were more engaged in the whole relationship that they have to these
animals that they were killing and eating.
Well,
I think
legacy,
if we're not careful,
you know,
our modern man,
I'm talking about our legacy in 2014 if we're not careful,
our legacy may very well be that we destroyed this earth,
you know,
I mean,
or made it a lot worse.
And that's,
that's really hard to stop with the onslaught of technology and all the,
you know,
just the,
the growth of our population and how many resources we need and the byproducts
and the wastes.
But,
uh,
that's,
that's a huge challenge man.
And I don't know the answer to how you stop it,
but
yeah,
it's interesting,
man.
It's,
it's really crazy.
Science is,
is probably the way we're going to figure out.
Yeah,
not probably,
I think it's the only way out.
Taking carbon out of the atmosphere,
growing food with less water and less space.
All that stuff.
Oh,
somebody corrected me.
The Dan Carlin episode is a,
the Prophets of doom.
That's the one that's on.
Um,
thanks to test from the shout out to the test bank profits on board.
That's the Dan Carlin episode.
But yeah,
I'm,
I,
I'm a really big optimist.
I mean,
I'm always hoping that we're going to get our shit together always.
But whether or not I am science is the answer or whether or not Ebola fixes the
problem or a super volcano,
we have to start all over again.
Like the Sumatra volcano.
I know,
but can you imagine if we had to start over?
I was thinking about that.
I was like,
no university.
So close to doing some cool stuff.
What is it cool stuff for?
Who's cool stuff for you?
You're not going to be here to see it.
Cool stuff for your kids.
I mean,
what w w our role is very strange.
Our role is very strange because we're a piece of a puzzle that likes to pretend
that we're the thing we're,
we're not,
we're a,
we're a grain of sand.
And even,
but I do think that what I think about is that what gives us meaning is all of
us,
no matter,
most of us at least,
unless you're a crazy person,
but all us are always working.
Like even even like Dawkins and people who are sort of nihilists people to say,
well,
you know,
we're,
we're a grant of San and none of this means anything.
It's all meaningless.
If that were the case,
they are still writing books to tell us how meaningful,
meaningless it is.
Everybody is very busy working very hard at their own expression.
And I think it's because when we were talking about this,
some people like,
you know,
they want to score social brownie points,
but for the most part human beings work very hard to try to at least influence
for the better.
The people that we love,
the people we're connected to,
the people that we are,
we're trying to make things better for ourselves.
But the reality is people that we love,
our sons
burning out our planet is going to no longer be able to support life.
Everything is temporary.
It's just the timeline is enormous.
So like is it doesn't have meaning.
Sure it has meaning currently,
but that's what we need to concern ourselves with.
What,
what happened?
What holds meaning to you and the people that you love.
Those things are important.
But the reality of life on this planet is,
first of all,
the reality of human beings.
You know,
we're joking around about one of my ancestors,
fucking a monkey.
But the reality is we are going,
if,
if human beings stay alive,
okay,
if civilization continues to innovate and we continue to get to this,
this insane progression of technology that we're currently involved in,
that keeps growing and keeps happening,
we will laugh at how goofy and apelike like we weren't 2014 in our search for me
machinery,
which is our,
our original biology.
It's already becoming obsolete.
Right?
That's sort of,
I mean at the very least it's,
it's,
it's outdated and it's,
we'll look at our bodies the way we look at a cell phone from the 80s as you're
able to like Mesh your body with machines and you become more efficient in
everything from holding your breath for an hour underwater or red blood cells to
keep you warm or whatever it might be.
Technology,
tissue,
regeneration,
nanotechnology,
robotics and,
and biocompatible machinery like that is going to change our very pilot
well,
which leads a whole new set of problems at a certain point in time.
Will we even be a person anymore?
And will we even be what we consider a carbon based life?
Exactly.
Because we're inventing synthetic biology.
And let's take it a step further,
uh,
as,
as you're able to download memory and you're,
if you're able to download memory,
if you're able to download what goes on in our brains,
some people criticize him.
You know,
I've seen people criticize his ideas saying that those things won't be possible.
But I think what they're missing is that we can replicate it without even
totally understanding it's processes.
Like the,
the,
the thing is what we don't understand all the complex processes of,
uh,
of,
you know,
utilizing proteins and this and that and how many steps and phases it takes to
create a human being.
But they could recreate what it is to be a human being without all those
processes if they have a different mechanism.
So instead of a biological mesic mechanism of cells and proteins and vitamins
and nutrients and you know,
neurotransmitters and all the different things that grow into being a person.
If it's silicon based,
if it's some sort of computer based system emulates all of the processes of
being a human being and does it better maybe.
Yeah,
very possible.
Very possible.
Yeah.
I mean look at that dude,
that guy that shot his wife in South Africa,
the blade runner do the stories.
Yeah.
I'll say that mother fucker with those stupid blades was running way faster
probably than he could have without them.
Yeah,
that's right.
Well and the other thing is that we learned more about the brain.
Like it,
it,
it really throws into question like you people to talk about having out of body
experiences.
Well,
what they found is they can,
they can manipulate,
they can touch parts of the brain that give people out of body experiences where
they feel like they're watching everything and their body.
Which is fascinating to me because that was always sort of the idea and we're
looking down as I was dying,
I could see myself and all that.
Well,
it may be that there's a chemical thing going on in the brain where you
actually,
you can actually manipulate that and replicate that process.
It's just not even maybe,
well,
here's the other thing we know about dreams.
Dreams are a very real thing.
Everyone.
I think everyone,
most people have dream.
Yeah.
So what is a dream?
A dream is an illusion.
It's not really happening.
What's something,
you were imagining something really intricate and DTI,
some fucking crazy dreams when we were sleeping in tents and in Alaska.
Really bizarre dreams.
So when you know,
you're talking about near death experiences,
the people are unconscious when they're having these like of like,
oh,
there's so much deep meaning to it really.
Well,
I was on a skateboard,
I was getting chased by Godzilla and a dream is there deep meaning in that
because both of them are illusions.
You weren't really flying above your body.
Okay.
And I wasn't really getting chased by Godzilla.
They both probably seemed equally real.
And the idea of a dream in an of itself is a very fucking strange thing.
You shut your brain off every night,
you close your eyes and your mind starts a process that we don't totally
understand.
We know there's a bunch of things happening like rem sleep,
rapid eye movement.
We know now that there's neurotransmitters that are moving in and out of the
brain and fucking around with your consciousness while you're out.
And we know what processes are shutting down and turn it off.
But we don't totally understand what dreaming is.
We don't understand it.
We really don't understand why we even need it.
It's amazing.
It's incredible.
So when someone talks about like having a near death experience,
like yeah,
maybe you're fucking dreaming,
you know,
like,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't know what happened.
You don't either.
And I know it changed me so much,
but I think eventually my father it out,
that's for sure.
At least be able to replicate dreams or have,
you know,
perhaps maybe we will transcend before we figure it down.
I mean we might abandon
the body before we even totally understand its processes.
It really throws into turmoil.
The people who have strict orthodox religious beliefs too.
I mean it's already fucked.
They're already fucked.
You know,
I was watching this video before you got here at Richard Dawkins arguing with
Islamic people and this guy was talking about how moral Islam is and how it's
important and ethics and this and that.
And Dawkins just kept hammering this dude.
He said,
what is the price that you must pay if you abandon Islam?
And the guy didn't want to answer it.
You got,
I didn't want to answer it.
And then he went back to it.
What is it?
A Pos.
A pasta fee state apostate.
But what's the,
what's the actual expression of leaving?
It's not,
you don't say,
oh I have,
I committed the stage.
You're in a pasta pasta fee,
so I don't know,
whatever it is.
What's the,
what?
What is,
what is,
what is the Jelly?
Right?
But what's the,
what is it like,
you know,
I don't know perjure yourself.
It's called perjury.
Whatever apostrophe I think it's called.
But anyway,
the guy wouldn't answer.
He didn't want to answer it.
He was trying to skirt around it and Dawkins kept hammering them.
It's finally,
he goes,
it's the death penalty.
He goes,
well,
there you go.
You leave Islam and it's you have to be killed.
It's that.
That's in your religion.
Don't understand it.
That's fucking crazy.
Like that's the death penalty.
And the guy was just like stammering.
He was just stuck there because that is the reality,
not only that in Islamic countries and do some insane number like in the 90
percentile believe that you should be stoned to death for adultery.
Well,
but,
but I have to just having lived there for a long time,
I do have to come to the defense of the fact that,
that those,
just like with,
with the book of Deuteronomy and Judaism,
which says exactly the same thing by the way,
most Muslims have,
you leave Christianity,
you get killed.
No.
And the dude book of Deuteronomy,
I mean a lot of those laws come from the Old Testament and remember that the
Quran was very heavily influenced by the Old Testament,
the Quran.
In many ways is a rebuttal to the New Testament saying that Jesus Christ is not
God.
But,
but,
but most of the 10 commandments and things are held as chronic laws.
Well,
okay,
so,
but it does it,
where's the debris from the old Jewish law?
Where does it ever say that if you leave Christianity,
you're supposed to be killed?
It doesn't,
I'm talking about,
I'm just saying that Islam got that from Judaism.
Okay.
That,
that's what I'm saying.
And so,
and,
but,
but the point I was making is that I don't understand Muslims.
I would,
I would guarantee,
I promise you don't believe that adultery,
that you should stone a woman to death the most.
Muslims aren't even that religious.
And there's this misconception and also Islam is very,
very the religion.
If you look at the difference between Indonesian Muslims for example,
and Wahabi Muslims who are in Saudi Arabia,
it's vastly different because the way they interpret the Quran,
the Quran is,
can be interpreted.
It's the most easily in widely interpreted religion as well.
It leaves very,
very,
very open for interpretation.
So,
so,
and that's what Nick Islamic scholars were always tell you in.
And most Muslims don't hold that
point of view.
Right.
But he's just not like saying that most Christians believe in evolution.
I mean it's like what is the,
what is the religion based on?
If you start deviating from it and adding in a bunch of your own thoughts and
then just sort of ignoring the old stuff like old and all that stuff they did.
Yeah.
But that does it.
But that does,
does that matter?
Because a bunch of people still do that.
That mean isn't the heart of it's still ridiculous.
I think that Dawkins though might be harping on an excel on,
on one aspect of Islam.
When,
when,
what?
No,
no,
he was,
he was talking in broad terms,
but he wanted to pick one very important point.
Like when people are talking about it being in a religion of peace,
he was saying really well,
how come if you leave you're supposed to be killed.
That's not peaceful.
I,
and,
and that's a very good point.
A very good question.
And an important question to ask.
I also think that there is also value in Islam too.
A lot of Muslims because it is a blueprint for how to live their lives and it
works for them.
Uh,
for example,
be charitable to people,
charities,
a very big part of Islam.
Um,
you know,
there are a lot of examples of that modesty charity and things like that.
It's when people take,
interpret these things,
literally I,
he fundamentally,
or if they take it as symbology as,
as,
as a suggestions for how to live here.
Just like you can be a Christian fundamentalist and you're going to be a very
different person than if you are a regular Christian who takes this symbolism,
Jamie,
pull up just Google,
not radical Islam and then pull up a video,
pull up videos from not radical Islam on Google.
And it's the very first video it's called.
It's not the radical,
it's Islam.
When,
I don't know what the word is.
S H,
a.
Y.
K.
H,
what's that word?
I Dunno how,
but anyway,
this guy is being interviewed.
This guy is communicating with this group of people.
And,
uh,
there are all these other Islamics or other Muslims,
and he's talking about how people are confused about what radical Islam is and
what's just actual Islam and what the,
what the law is and what you're supposed to do.
And watch this video.
They always attack the Muslims or Islam in particular while for cert.
Can't hear example about gays and put your headphones on the old as the Coulson
and the teachings of,
towards this matter.
For example,
while in Christianity in Judaism it's the same punishment,
uh,
that exists.
It's Harambe.
And so why they're always,
for example,
focusing on Islam and not a Judaism or Christianity.
While for example,
also in Jerusalem for those who've been to Jerusalem and the bosses in
Jerusalem,
for example,
women's sits separate than men for example.
You know,
so why like five minutes ago or,
or early,
we were asked about why Muslims,
uh,
has to be sitting separate men and women,
but they never ask a these questions to Jews or Christians.
Why specifically Muslims or Islam?
Didn't you answer this question yesterday?
And you said that you need to ask the media.
Yeah.
Yes,
it's true.
Yeah.
He wasn't a tear,
but the other people were here.
Yeah,
there are there people who will suffer because of you.
The answer's very simple.
Islam as the truth and in Christianity and Judaism and not the truth.
This topic may I shift,
but you are the chef.
You're the doctor.
I said,
can we have the camera?
Can we have this camera focusing on all the audience?
Sarah,
can we have this camera focusing on older audience because
every now and then,
every time we have a conference,
every time we invite a speaker,
they always can come with the same accusations.
This speaker supports death penalty for homosexuals.
This speaker supports death penalty for this crime,
this crime that he is homophobic,
they subjugate women,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
It's the same old stuff coming all the time and we always try to tell them.
I always try to tell them that,
look,
it's not that speaker that we are in whiting who has this extreme radical views.
As you say,
these are general views that every Muslim actually has.
Every Muslim believes in these things.
Just because they're not telling you about it.
Just because they're not out there in the media doesn't mean they don't believe
in them.
So I would ask you,
everyone in the room,
how many of you are normal Muslims do not extremists.
They're not radical.
This is normal Sunni Muslims.
Please raise your hands.
Everybody.
Mashallah.
Panela okay,
take down your hands again.
How many of you agree that men and women should sit separate?
Please raise your hands.
All of them raised their hands.
Yeah,
both lunch.
This is everyone agreed.
Everyone agreed.
The brothers and sisters,
it's not just this radical shifts.
Then Allahu Akbar.
Next question.
How many of you agree that the punishments described in the n and the sooner
whether it is death,
whether it is stoning for adultery,
whatever it is,
if it is from a and his messenger,
that is the best punishment ever possible for humankind.
And that is what we should apply in the world.
Well homer,
who agrees with that and they all raise their hand a lot of work.
But are you all the radical extremists?
Panela.
So all of you are saying that you are common Muslims,
you all go to the different massages?
No Way.
Or is it,
are you like a specific sector like the Islam,
that sec to anything like that?
Are you like that?
Nah.
Is it the [inaudible] please raise your hand if you like this extreme Islam,
that sector or anything like that.
No one a lot work.
But how many of you just go to this normal massage massage?
It's in Norway.
The normal student.
Pseudonymous please raise your hands.
Raise your hands.
Allahu Akbar.
God is great.
What's the politicians going to say now?
What does the media going to say now that we're all extremists were all
radicals.
We need to deport all of us from this country had a law,
a law hawk,
but duck,
duck beer.
It's a beer.
Maybe have the next question please.
I don't,
come on.
I don't.
I don't like those kind of videos to be honest with you because I,
I happen to think that if you took a cross section of people from all over the
Muslim world,
you'd find very different points of view.
You'd find people who were way more liberal than that guy.
Uh,
and I think it's because people are living their lives.
They don't even have time to go to mosque.
Just like you see with Christians,
just like you see what Jews,
there's a great deal of debate.
I think the problem with the Muslim world today is a most moderate Muslims and
that's most are just silent.
Okay?
But what does that mean though?
What it means?
What it means,
said he's saying on stage when he's asking you,
are you,
are you regular Muslims?
And if you are regular with slums,
raise your hand.
They raise their hand.
If you believe that the message that's in the Koran is the correct way to handle
any situation,
raise your hand if you believe that it's the way to handle adultery.
Raise your hand and they're all raising their hand.
Those are real people.
They're not real people.
I don't know who those people are like,
Whoa,
what does that mean?
What does that mean?
I don't know.
There's people that are going on,
whether it is,
I don't know what the context is.
I mean,
I don't think that's a good example
because the room people full of people like that in that clip is not,
not necessarily a good representation of most Muslims.
It just isn't.
I,
you know,
I think there are problems with Islam like any other religion.
I think there are problems with certain populations of,
of Muslims who have an isolated,
there's a lot of,
there might be a lot of ignorance in certain parts of the world,
like the Middle East where there isn't a lot of money or exposure to other
ideas.
Yes,
but I think that that is,
that is very anti-Islamic in very slanted in its own way.
Wait a minute,
what is just just taking a,
not the,
I'm not saying you,
I'm saying when you,
when,
if you took that and you look at one video and decide that's how Muslims think
in general.
I think it's a mistake.
First of all,
this video is a pro Islam site that puts this video of this video was put up by
Islam net video,
islam.net and what they're trying to tell you is that these ideas that people
are calling radical Islam are not radical.
They are just Islamic ideas.
This is not like a proper arm to video.
I've read the Quran.
They are,
but it we'll put home saying is this is not a propaganda video.
This is a pro Islamic website that's putting these videos out.
I understand.
All I'm saying is that that fee that to me that that video to me leaves non
Muslims with the impression that all Muslims are extreme and what I'm saying is
I don't believe that they are.
I mean this country,
a Christian country for all intents and purposes puts a great number of people
to death and we have a lot of people on death row for four crimes especially in
the state is non sec.
It is a secular thing.
It's not done because of religion.
When you put people in jail or kill them because of murder.
You're not doing it because it's in the Bible,
but our justice system is very much based on the notion that everybody said the
same world we're worth,
which is a Christian idea.
Yeah,
but because it's a Christian idea,
it's not based on the Christian faith,
meaning you have to be a Christian to ascribe to it.
Like these ideas are very,
this is very different.
Like no one is saying that God says that we should kill people for adultery,
so we have to kill people for adultery in this country.
Like we're talking about crimes against other human beings.
That's the reason why people were killed in this country.
I mean,
when you're killing someone in Texas for murder,
I understand you're not doing it because it's a crime against God.
What what you're seeing in that video is a religion.
You're seeing a representation of religion.
Are there more moderate representations of that religion?
It's an unquestionably.
There certainly are,
but at what point in time,
what is the religion then?
I mean if becomes more moderate and if you don't ascribe to certain things that
are in this ancient texts that tell you there's very clear laws and rules that
you're supposed to abide by.
It's the question.
That's a weird question.
What is the religion then?
What is a religion at all?
If you just decide,
well,
we're going to morph it because it's 2014 and we think that the new evidence
show that homosexuals are actually born and it's not their fault,
it's just a part of genetics and it's part of life itself.
It's like having red hair or a big nose.
You some people are gay and that's a really,
really good question and I think that,
I think in my opinion,
I think you could,
you could identify as a Christian,
as a Muslim,
as a,
as a Jew and not hold all the tenants of that particular religion,
but why then what is a,
are you just a human that just accepts you?
You pull and choose and play.
We'll do it all the time,
right,
but what is that then?
How are you a Christian?
You're not subscribing to the full ideology.
You're,
you're not a fundamentalist,
but what are you?
Then you're,
you're,
you're
a believer who believes in the,
in not in the letter of the law,
but rather in the symbol,
in the idea,
in the suggestion and the idea that we can reach to be as good as we can be and
that some laws that were written 15 1400 years ago in this case or whatever,
I think that's how long it was our outdated because science,
et Cetera,
is starting to show us that a lot of those laws do not hold relevance in our
everyday lives and in fact are probably unethical or immoral.
But isn't that completely fascinating when you look at all these different
countries that do believe that if you leave Islam,
you are,
you're a dead person.
You should be killed.
If you commit adultery,
you're a dead person.
You should be killed.
I mean,
there's a bunch of different things.
If you are homosexual,
you should be killed with raw,
very important questions to ask.
And very important for the Muslim world to debate.
And they're going through that debate right now.
Just like Judaism and Christianity went through that debate.
I mean,
how many people were burned at the stake in,
in,
in the name of,
of,
you know,
witchcraft in Salem and all over Europe for that matter because they were not
what could Christians,
um,
you know,
so I think,
I think this is a product of a religion under,
you know,
I think actually that these debates and the questions you're asking,
which are also being asked in the Muslim world are crucial because it's how a
religion,
you know,
it's,
it's the,
it's the process or religion must go through and contend with.
It's got the favor or oppose making sharia the law of the land.
This is the percentage of Muslims who favor making Islamic law the official law
in their country ready for this.
Afghanistan,
99% Pakistan,
84% Bangladesh,
82% Iraq,
91% Palestine,
89% Morocco,
83% I mean these are crazy numbers.
Niger in Subsaharan Africa,
86% a lot of this country's,
how I would,
I would imagine are also very poor and I don't know how they're polling,
but I think a lot of us,
those countries,
when you've got nothing,
you turned to religion.
Now the way you solve that problem is with commerce.
Yeah,
right.
It is a,
it is a scary thought though,
that we're in this part of the world.
There's a giant chunk of human beings that have these ideals.
I mean these are,
these are ideas that are incredibly common in giant chunks of the world.
Millions of people.
And when you're talking about what a religion is,
and there's so many moderates,
well,
what is this religion then?
I mean,
if there are moderates who don't believe you should be stoned to death,
who don't believe that you should be killed if you leave,
who don't believe he's killed should be chilled with rocks if you're an adult or
what is that religion then?
I mean at what point in time does it sort of dwindle off?
Does it go away?
Does it Iraq is place apple like that statistic is very surprising to me and I'm
not sure I believe it because Iraq was,
remember it was basically under Saddam Hussein.
You weren't really allowed to even bring a Koran to school or to a public place.
It was the sheer our way are,
are,
are a little bit more religious in some ways then,
then the,
then the Sunni,
although that's,
that's a big actually with Isis.
Those are,
they are,
they believe in Wahab and Wa in Wahhabi,
Wahhabi Islam and stuff.
But,
um,
I,
I think that,
you know,
Iraq from what I understand was essentially,
um,
they were baptists,
which was the idea was that you were secular,
that,
that all Arab should band together and there should be sort of this belt of Arab
unity,
uh,
which was what a Nazi was trying to do in Egypt,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Unify the Arabs under one sort of,
but,
but so I'm going to say it was very sort of until later on was very anti Islam
in a lot of ways.
Yeah.
Well that was a secular nation.
It was a secular nation before we invaded it.
And now it's a civil war between two varying sects of Islam.
Yeah.
It's just to me,
I think that ideologies are very dangerous and they are rigid ideologies that
are thousands of years old are the most dangerous hundred percent.
Speaking of seventh heaven.
Oh boy.
There's a show that Brian used to be on a religious show.
Right?
I mean,
I have to pee because I want to talk about this.
Very good.
Go,
go do your little squirt and we'll,
we'll talk about this,
this
because this is fucking really spooky stuff.
There was a show called seventh heaven and Brian was on it.
He,
uh,
I don't remember the exact nature of the show,
but it had something to do with religion.
Um,
he,
so anyway,
this guy whose name is Steven Collins,
uh,
he played a pastor on this show,
seventh heaven.
He confessed to his estranged wife that he was a child molester and it's all on
tape apparently.
Um,
she recorded,
they were having meetings with the counselor and um,
she recorded him talking to this therapist and she was asking him all these
questions about these incidents and uh,
he was very specific about the answers and she taped the therapy session and
apparently it's legal to secretly record a conversation because in California
you're allowed to secretly record conversations to gather evidence that the
other person committed a violent felony and molesting a child under the age of
14 is considered a violent felony.
This is amazing stuff.
Um,
they,
there was a,
he confessed to molesting and 11 year old girl,
a relative of his first wife.
That's so sick,
man.
He,
I mean,
he's talking in,
in,
in great detail about these things.
Uh,
he,
he did it a few times.
This one girl when she was 11,
12 or 13,
and this guy,
I mean,
he was playing a pastor.
This is,
uh,
I,
it's,
it's really sick.
Well,
what's,
what's crazy is that I have on my acting real,
there's a scene with him and I doing the scenes,
one of the best things I ever did.
And it's really weird because I knew him really well.
I know him very well.
And
you know,
usually when you read about this,
you go,
well that guy,
that guy's,
that guy should be put in jail right away and all that stuff.
And it's an interesting thing because I've been thinking about it like,
I feel like,
and I want to be careful how I say this because I know him well.
I feel like this is,
uh,
this is,
a guy who's a good guy with a sickness,
like a,
like a compulsion,
a sickness.
So when you say good guy,
I think that,
I don't know man.
I just,
I find myself shaking my head and scratching my head,
but I know Steven well and I think,
I think it's possible.
Is it possible that you are you,
you mean good to everybody,
your fellow man.
Yet you have a compulsion and a sickness that you don't know what to do about.
And this article that I was reading to you about in a,
we were on the plane and there was an article in New York Times written about
pedophilia and how a lot of pedophiles have these urges.
They don't act on them.
They live in fear.
They have no control sometimes.
And this woman was saying,
if those people,
because all of us want to punish somebody like that,
right?
The minute we see that guy,
I have daughter,
you have daughters.
It's like,
I don't want that guy on the street.
I don't want to go onto your kids.
We understand that and we all go,
we've got to get that guy in jail,
but there's a bigger question to say and that is this.
If you have these feelings,
you're a pedophile and you have these feelings,
you just have these urges is shouldn't there be somewhere for these people to go
where they can,
where they can say,
I'm having these feelings.
I need help because I feel like I'm going to touch a child.
That seems to be creating a place for those people to go and somehow seek help,
I feel is more important.
Then if they,
if they,
if they don't have anywhere to go to for help and they know that they go
anywhere,
they're going to lose their jobs and lose their life and everything else,
they're not going to go anywhere.
They're going to touch a kid.
It's at the end results here is we have to figure out a way so less kids get,
you know,
molested.
Right,
right.
It raises a very difficult debate and question,
which is if this is indeed a sickness and there's a lot of evidence that may be,
it is even neurological,
like there's an overwhelming number of pedophiles that are lefthanded and
overwhelming number of pedophiles that have trouble with spacial relationships.
Was that in the New York Times article that you were reading on the plane?
Yes.
For that.
So fascinating.
This came out today.
Yeah.
And then here's this friend of mine who I really,
really like.
I mean he's a,
he's just funny and the,
and does a lot of work for charities?
Got Kids of his own.
Well,
apparently it wasn't just one instance.
No,
LAPD is reopening an investigation from 2012 where his niece of a neighbor.
Yeah.
And he went,
I guess he admitted it to his wife and then he went to counseling,
which I talked about it while you went in the bathroom and it was
all recorded by his wife and the recording is legal because he was uh,
doing a violent crime.
It's awful.
It's really awful.
Oh Man.
I Dunno.
I'm just,
I'm shaking my head.
I don't know,
but I do think that it,
oh,
it is a very important debate to have is that if it's considered,
if it's a mental,
a form of
a mental illness,
should they have somewhere to go to say,
Hey,
I have these urges.
I don't want to touch kid.
Please help me.
It should there be a safe haven for pedophiles to get help so they don't touch
children or at least it lowers the chances that they will tell to touch on them.
That's the difficult question to ask.
Yeah,
it's,
it's some scary shit,
you know,
to think that you could be a person that is in all other ways a normal person,
but like a crack head around crack compelled like you,
you have an alcoholic.
Can you set a glass of whiskey in front of them and you pour a glass of whiskey?
I mean they are drawn to that whiskey.
It's like a sickness,
but that whiskey is not hurting anybody other than themselves.
When you see someone who's a pedophile and they're drawn to children,
we tend to lose all of our sympathy and all of our understanding.
And it's because we want to protect our people.
You know,
we want to protect our family children.
But could you imagine,
I mean,
I'm not being sympathetic towards child molesters.
believe me,
I'm the least sympathetic.
I have a very primal urge to break his fucking head open with a rock.
Right?
But imagine being this poor fuck.
I mean,
what is it about him that makes him want to go to this 11 year old girl and put
her hand on his chick?
It's fucked.
But that was on that show for two years.
I worked with him.
What was the premise of the show was an American family.
Like they basically,
the premise was this is the perfect family and they're an example for everyone.
And he was a minister and the father and he had,
he had a wife and children.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and I played this,
I remember I,
my first scene I played this alcoholic comes back in this kid Peter's life and
he counsels me,
you know,
I'm a real,
a whole and he counsels me and you know,
and,
and I really got to know him because we had so many scenes together and spend a
lot of time,
did a reading forum,
I've talked to him on the phone about sag and all kinds of stuff.
And it's just fucking,
it's just,
I dunno man.
So this is confirmed.
I,
you never would've thought that dude.
Like,
you know what I mean?
That's the other thing.
Like some people you go,
there's no way I,
well of course that's a,
that's a good person who I'd leave my kid with that,
you know,
anyway,
I,
it's,
you just don't know.
You don't know man.
You don't know what goes on the inner recesses of someone's brain.
But I do think,
I do think this is a case,
if there's ever been one,
I don't know anything.
I'm not an expert,
but of of,
of a good person with a sickness,
you know,
of a guy.
I Dunno.
I'm just,
I don't even know what to say about it.
It's dark,
it's dark shit,
dark,
scary,
awful stuff.
And then I started
thinking about other things that are really hard to even talk about.
Like,
like there's what is,
and there's molestation of a child.
We already know what it does.
Most people the revulsion and what you want to do.
And then there are different levels of molestation that nobody really talks
about touching and then actual sex.
Right.
And one I would imagine,
and I have to believe is way more traumatic than the other.
Yeah.
I don't know how the law sees it,
but yeah,
the guy's life is done.
I think it's sexist sex.
I mean,
I think the law sees it.
Like if you're involving genitals and touching,
I mean it's one thing if there's sexual misconduct though,
and then there's a salt,
right?
So one is penetration I think,
and the other calling this violence sex and that's the reason why she was
allowed.
Or he rather,
uh,
the woman rather his wife.
I was right.
The first time she was allowed to record him in these counseling sessions is
because it's violent sex.
But what is violence?
This where it's a violent crime,
not violence,
but it falls under the umbrella of violent crime.
Right?
But what is violence isn't violent.
I thought violence is like trauma.
I thought violence is like aggression.
If,
if someone takes your hand and gently puts it on their dick,
it's awful.
Right?
Right.
Obviously evil.
But is that violent?
Because if he's dating a woman and he takes his hand and,
or it takes her hand and put,
puts it on his dick,
that's not violent.
Right.
Or is it thought to be violent?
If she didn't want him to do that?
Here's me.
I mean she resists like,
so let's say,
let's say he's with a woman,
they'd go back to his place,
they're having a glass of wine,
they're just talking and he put,
takes her hand and he puts it on his Dick and you know,
and she resists and then he lets go.
It was that violent.
Well,
what if he takes her hand and he puts it on his dick and she struggles the whole
way that's violent.
But if she doesn't resist at all and she just goes,
he was being inappropriate.
I saw assuming.
Yeah.
What,
what is violent?
I mean it will,
the word violence,
weird word.
I mean I guess we're kind of having a conversation about semantic.
No,
you're not.
You have to have no,
but why violence?
But because first of all,
I think there is a difference between anal rape and,
Oh yeah.
Vaginal rape and being touched.
I was,
when I was a kid in camp,
I was 11 I was,
I guess technically molested by my camp counselor who was an old man in his
forties and he was touching me and funneling me.
I woke up and he had his hand in my pants and he was playing with my,
my,
you know,
my piece,
my gack.
And I remember going,
I remember being 11 gone.
This is weird man.
He's got a beard and he smells weird and he's touching my wiener.
I don't think this makes sense.
So other than I'd tell my friend John and Donnie,
I go,
hey,
did,
did he touch you down there?
And my friend done?
He goes,
yeah,
he sucked me down there and then my buddy John Goes,
he touched me too,
so I go,
I'm going to tell my mom and I marched,
but my mother was coming for parent weekend was I was away at camp.
My mother and I went right up to it.
I go,
Hey,
that guy touched mine big.
He sucked on his dick and he touched Johnson and my mind went right to the
camera and the guy back then,
this was probably,
I dunno,
what was it,
1978 or whatever.
He got fired and just send on his way.
There was no criminal thing.
Yeah,
it was,
it said on the way.
And when they told his wife he was married,
when he told his wife,
his wife laughed and said,
Oh God,
he's up to that again.
Yes.
And My mother told me that.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
His wife laugh.
Yes,
and said he's up to that.
Yes.
She was the arts and craft counselor.
She had shorter anyway.
But listen,
it's strange how much our attitudes about those types of changes have changed
really,
really radically.
Well,
I think because we,
people are more open to talk about it and talk about the damage it did when they
were kids.
And I think the point I'm raising is that it all depends on the circumstances,
the level of molestation and what kind.
I don't think that damaged me,
but I can't speak for this girl.
Look at me.
I'm a mess.
I'm a mess from that one.
Mamike a beard and a hand on the Dick.
But you do have to have that conversation about levels of degree.
Because if you don't,
then it's not fair to people who are really raped and you know,
I mean who are vaginally and Ainsley and all that other stuff.
There's a difference.
Well,
that's why this whole yes means yes.
Law,
which was recently passed in California,
is it's kind of offensive to people that have actually been raped.
If you don't know this law,
the idea being that a lack of resistance does not equal consent and you must get
consent.
And so if someone's taken all the romance out of sex,
by the way holds,
it's crazy,
but,
but I guess I kind of see why they're doing it.
I kind of see that they don't want someone to feel like they were overwhelmed by
someone and they didn't know what to do and they couldn't say anything.
And so they think that by forcing people to say,
yes,
I want to have sex with you that this would,
but then it's also feminists want to be able to withdraw consent after the fact
if they feel like they were tricked.
So they want to be able to cry.
Rape if you manipulated and lied to them.
Like I said,
I love you,
make love to me and they have sex.
I don't love you.
You fucking kidding me.
No,
I'm not.
that's,
that's a real tenant of some forms of radical feminism.
They,
they want to be able to withdraw consent after the fact.
Well,
those Luna can say what they want,
but here's what I,
this is why I think that's lunacy and why I think it's so insulting.
If you're gang raped,
you're held down by a stranger APP.
Now there's a couple apps for the iPhone.
Uh,
there's one called good to go.
What does,
this one's good to go?
Yeah.
You like,
I don't even know if it does it work on fingerprints or something like that?
What does it work on?
Fingerprint.
Yeah.
Some of them work on fingerprints grow and you have an app and I have an APP and
you click yes and I click yes and fuck,
what are we doing?
You know,
that's that,
that's fucking lunacy in my opinion.
And I think it's a real insult to people who have been
held down and raped by strangers or,
or of,
they know in a violent manner.
You know,
it's,
there are,
I do think that there are times when somebody can be,
you know,
that a woman is so overwhelmed,
she yet,
she doesn't know what to say and she gets raped.
I'm not a woman.
I don't know what the fuck goes on.
Okay.
And there's 100%.
I understand that there's date rape and all that stuff.
There's also times where you really wish you said no and you don't like when
it's happening and you don't know what to do and you just sit there and a guy
has sex with you.
Yes,
but I don't know what that is.
Is that sexual assault?
How was the man's supposed to know?
If you don't say anything,
there's,
there's that and if you do say something and the man continues,
well that's rape,
right?
If he say,
please stop.
You know,
don't take my pants off.
Don't have sex with me,
and the guy does it anyway.
We'll both agree that's right.
Yes.
So w but then there's a problem.
They're trying to say that if you're consuming alcohol.
I had Thaddeus Russell and podcast.
Okay.
He's a professor at Occidental,
Occidental College or university.
We never figured it out.
It's called the college.
Okay.
He was a professor at this college where these two kids,
they were both freshmen.
They were both young.
They got drunk,
they had sex,
and the girl decided that it was rape because she was drunk when they had sex.
Meanwhile on her text messages,
she's sending a text message to her friend.
Um,
she sent a text message to him.
He's saying,
come over here.
She says,
do you have a condom?
He says,
yes.
She texts her friend,
I'm about to go have sex.
She went over to his house.
She had sex with them and then afterwards the college decided that this was rape
because she was intoxicated,
but he was intoxicated too.
They're both intoxicated.
They're communicating back and forth to each other,
but somehow or another he's responsible for his actions.
He was expelled from college.
She wasn't.
It sounds like it like people who hate men,
it's feminism.
Yeah.
That's a big part of what some feminism is.
Not all feminism.
A lot of feminism is just striving for equality.
Yeah.
I'm a,
I'm a feminist international.
Yes.
In that sense.
Yeah,
but the real problem is one of the women at Occidental College that fattiest
Russell referenced who co counsel this.
This girl said that he fits the profile ready for this,
for being a rapist because he came from a good family because he's a
Valedictorian and because he's on a sports team.
Wow.
Wow,
wow.
Terrifying.
He an under achiever I guess.
And then you won't be a rate how terrified he said that he's privileged because
it comes from a good family that he's on a sports team.
So he embraces the jock culture of,
of,
of sexual assault and shocks don't,
but whatever,
you know,
and that he's a Valedictorian.
So because he's successful,
he's got this like drive to succeed,
which could lead him to being a rapist.
What the fuck got expelled?
He got expelled,
we suing and there's a big lawsuit.
But look,
his life is changed.
Her life has changed.
Both their lives are changed and it's what happened.
They got trunk and they fucked man.
And that is,
Russell had a really good point that I've always said is that one of the
problems with women and sex is that we have this idea still in our heads.
A lot of people do that.
Sex is a bad thing.
And that a man having sex with a girl at the girls,
he's done something to her taking something from her.
And a lot of it comes from a bunch of fucking idiots that think that a woman
having sex with a man is a bad thing.
So she gets shamed for it.
So she feels bad for being shamed,
for having sex.
And so she equates that with her having been a like a crime's been committed on
her because people will make you feel bad because you,
you owe that guy fucked you.
Oh you loser.
Like no,
no,
you had sex,
you're normal,
you're alive,
you're a person,
you have hormones.
It feels good.
You did it cause you wanted to do it.
And men and women do it.
And our puritan values and are ridiculous notions,
completely unequal that a woman can have sexual experiences with a guy and more
than one man and she's a fucking slut.
But if a guy does it,
he's a stud.
It's stupid,
it's stupid.
And it's all based on pure it and values.
And it's a lot of,
it's based on the time before birth control and disease.
When you didn't have antibiotics,
you had to be very careful he had sex with,
but birth control,
no Joe,
a woman having this,
these responsibilities that she has to worry about becoming impregnated.
You know,
we're a guy can just fucking shoot loads all fucking willy nilly to the cows,
come home and not worry about a God damn thing happening to his body.
Celebrate a woman has to be concerned every time she has intercourse that she
might have to raise a child,
drop out of school or have an abortion.
Those are those,
the the real cold hard facts and so this,
this ground is very uneven but now you add in birth control,
which is why a lot of people believe like one of the radical changes in society
in this culture was in the 1950s when they invented,
or sixties when they invented Bert.
When did they invent birth control?
Fifties or sixties one of those is the sixth massive change,
massive change in the way human beings interacted,
males and females,
because all of a sudden the women's liberation movement happened.
Women were allowed to have sex and not worry about constantly having to worry
about being pregnant and having babies with these dudes.
Well,
they just wanted to fuck.
They're just young people wanting to live their life and wanted to do what their
hormones we're telling them to do to enjoy it.
It's one of the great fun things in life is a man and a woman having sex and the
this idea that two people having sex if they're drunk is rape.
The problem with it is it's only rape for the girl.
It's not raped for the guy and no one is ever going to argue that if a guy and a
girl get together and they have a couple of drinks and the girl gets on top of
the guy and has sex with them,
that the guy got raped,
no one is ever going to argue that you can't take it to court,
you'll be laughed out of court.
So that's really unfair and really uneven.
And it's a response to the really unfair and really uneven views that we have
about men and women and their sexuality.
So you may,
right now we're seeing a pendulum,
we're seeing the high end of the pendulum and we're going to come back and eat.
Yeah,
well we're,
we're seeing a reaction.
I mean,
we're seeing reaction to the sex that's been marginalized,
that females have been marginalized,
that they had been oppressed.
And then look,
rape is fucking real as shit man.
Like we were in Alaska and one of the things that we talked about where we're in
Alaska with people that live there is how many people get raped up there and
that these women,
women who live in Alaska,
you're dealing with high rates of alcoholism.
You're dealing with isolated populations and you're dealing with a lot of rape.
Well,
because there are few women,
very few moments need to to men and something crazy,
like seven to one crazy men to one woman.
Yeah.
So let girls,
if you look at for Dick,
oh,
Asca,
Alaska,
a lot of rugged men.
But did you ever see they have those posters like the men of old calendars,
these to sell the Gals,
the men of Alaska and dude's fucking cowboy hats,
giant dogs.
Then they would have fly fishing pole.
I like to fish and fuck.
Yeah.
That's a funny thing about pornography when it comes to women,
like some women enjoy watching men and women have sex,
but very few women like playgirl like playgirl and looking at you guys' Cox.
Yeah,
that's for dudes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Playgirl is for fucking dudes.
If you're a guy and you post for playgirl,
you're doing gay porn.
Sorry.
I know you don't want to think.
No,
no,
no.
Bro.
Beth that can girls who liberated man watching more and more women apparently
are watching porn.
Dude,
I w I looked at one playgirl once,
once just once,
gun to my head and a guy was like doing like,
what's that baby happy baby position?
You're lying down,
your feet are,
and he was holding down the legs,
ankles.
He was holding his feet and his fucking cock was like three quarters hard
because you're not allowed to show hard cocks.
And those magazines because hard Cox is hardcore pornography.
Very strange.
Softix when I was a kid porn,
you weren't allowed to show hard ons.
You had to show like semis only semis.
It was very strange.
So like all porn scenes where guys like they were making pastries,
they're all like squeezing the base of their Dick.
Like they were trying to write happy birthday with a cock.
That was,
that was all porn.
That was all,
all magazines.
There was no like penetration in magazines.
So all you got red tube and x,
x and x and all of that show.
It's,
it's changed like our or ability to view sex has changed so radically that
people apparently,
especially kids are engaging in way more sex,
way more sex early and also the kind of sex that watch on TV cause they think a
lot of the women think they have to go.
Girls think they have to keep up with the boys fantasies because they've been
watching all this porn and boys get really bored too.
Apparently the,
and I've heard,
I've read studies or heard about studies where a lot of boys will,
um,
like when you and I were growing up just seeing a naked girl,
we weren't looking at imperfections.
We were like,
holy fucking shit.
She's naked.
New.
Yeah.
Now have access to,
you know,
these women that have been surgically enhanced and Photoshop and all that stuff.
And with makeup and,
and you know,
they're linear,
they're I their appreciation for linear lines and you know,
all that stuff is way more height and they're way more picky.
And so a lot of women,
they'll kind of start,
they'll go with one girl and then they'll go to the next girl.
And there's a lot more of that apparently.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Apparently it's,
it's,
it's amazing though that we,
we have all these weird hangups in this day and age when it comes to sex.
And I think a lot of it has to be,
because it's like sexual attraction is not an even thing.
I mean,
have you ever been around a woman who was not sexually attractive,
but she has a friend who's sexually attractive?
There's a lot of the women who are nonsexual,
attractive,
get fucking aggressive.
They don't like men.
They tried to keep men away from their friend and they're trying to protect
their friend it,
but under the guise,
but it's not their cock blockers.
There are hardcore cock blockers because they're angry that they're not sexually
attractive in a lot of it is just a fucking genetic roll of the dice.
Like you have perfect bone structure.
Your nose is the perfect shape,
your body's perfect shape and everybody's gravitating towards you.
But you go to the person on the left and this person,
they are,
you know,
the dad was goofy looking,
their mom was goofy looking and you know,
and then they make goofy looking kids and it's just,
there's nothing that goofy looking kid can do about it.
But when,
you know,
when you're talking about these,
these for radical feminists who are coming up with these laws or whatever they,
again,
this is,
this is the lunatic fringe.
This is an example of we can bring them back to the t to the Islam debate,
you know?
Yeah.
There are,
I believe that these people are unreasonable and there are a lot of people in
religion that are unreasonable.
And,
and I think that that these feminists who are pushing these laws are very
similar to the two fundamentalists.
They are religious in their own way.
They had their own orthodoxy,
their own fundamentalism,
their own very strong ideas of what rape is and rape is anything,
anything that they deem it to be in this,
in this case they put rape.
They put,
uh,
somebody who didn't necessarily say they want to have sex on the same ground as
somebody who was violently raped by some stranger in a parking lot at knife
point,
whatever.
And it's the same kind of human con.
Some people have this need to be unreasonable to be fundamentalist and their
beliefs.
And,
and it is in its own way a prison of belief.
It is very similar to the kind of,
uh,
in this,
in the case we were talking about with Islam for that very similar mindset as a
Islamic fundamentalists.
Well,
it's a lot of people are angry.
Look,
there's a lot of men who are angry at women.
Okay.
The angry male movement,
like there's the men's rights movement.
There's a lot of those guys are fucking very angry at women.
There's a lot of the pickup artist movement.
God,
those guys,
there's a lot of them.
Not all of them,
but a lot of them that I've read,
I've read forums,
I've listened to these guys talk and videos.
There's a lot of them that are clearly angry with women.
And one of the big arguments,
one of the big,
uh,
the big points of contention,
the big things they're pissed off about is them not being attractive to women.
Because women want money.
Women want status,
women want good looking guys.
They want this,
they want that.
So these pickup artists are showing you ways to circumnavigate that ways.
But there's this one video with this guy and long hair and he's trying to be
like a cool guy.
He's like,
I don't give a fuck if you were in a wheelchair.
I saw,
have you seen this video?
Tony says,
he,
she had a fuck.
He's somebody he wanted.
He wanted to be in my podcast.
I was like,
it was fucking preposterous.
He's disgusting.
And what these,
this idea is based on the fact that there's some people that just women don't
find attractive and they feel like it's not fair.
So they go out,
they try to pick,
they're gonna manipulate their way until her pants was a trying to,
because otherwise they're not going to get in there.
They're just not.
You know?
And why?
One of the reasons why a lot of this is an issue and this is what's really
fucked up.
Prostitution's illegal and prostitution should be fucking legal.
You know?
And if prostitution was legal and it was sanctioned and women were tested,
have an outlet,
you would have an outlet and men would,
wouldn't have to like feel always that there's no way and no one's ever going to
touch them.
It's true.
He wants to think that there's something awful and terrible about prostitution.
Look,
I don't want my daughter becoming a prostitute,
but guess what?
I don't want my daughter working at Wendy's either.
I don't want my daughter being a waitress.
If someone can give you a massage and a massage is totally legal.
What does a massage?
It's someone they don't want to touch you.
Okay.
They're touching you because you're paying them.
That's right.
And you feel good when they touch you.
Why is that okay?
But jerking you off is not okay.
In Asian countries,
they don't feel that way.
In a matter of fact,
in a lot of those countries,
massage with a jerk off at the end is a natural part of massage.
Or what about just a woman who,
who,
who is willing to die for a certain price?
Fuck you shit.
She's in command of her own body.
She's willing to engage in a transaction with you,
an economic transaction.
You want to touch this?
No problem.
It's on my terms.
No problem on her anal.
And why can't she make her rate?
Why can't you say,
look,
do you want to have sex with me?
If you're kind to me and you're nice,
I will have sex with you.
I want $5,000 right.
You know,
and she can have sex once a month and that's it.
And she doesn't have to work for the rest of the fucking month.
She gets all of her bills paid and she's done right.
Where does she know?
Shit.
It's,
it's,
but it's the idea of being that that person is a Sicko.
But we were talking about,
um,
dominatrixes while we were in camp and one of the things we were talking about
was like how weird it is that people like a lot of like really rich and powerful
men especially pay to get dominated by women.
Like women will tie them up and fucking rope their balls to the ground and all
that shit you were talking to me about.
And that's okay.
Like somehow under the,
that's okay.
Like that falls it because the guy is kind of being brutalized.
Like it's okay.
Even if it's like sexual,
it's,
it's like weird,
but if it's just straight sex,
you know,
if the woman puts our mouth in the guy's penis for 10 minutes,
escalation I guess or whatever.
Well that had,
doesn't I have it.
It's origins in religion,
religion.
And so again,
this is where to nature of this country.
And so that,
that again is what I'm saying about we live in a very religious country in many
ways.
And whenever you look at Islam or you look at Christianity,
I believe that the majority of people from any religion,
if you really talk to them,
hey,
we have a lot more in common.
Americans have a lot more in common with,
I bet I bet a lot of the average Arab on the street,
and I've got to,
if you really get them alone,
a lot more in common than you think.
I mean,
my God,
we want Ma,
I guarantee most of them want some saying who governs them.
Most people have doubts about their religion.
Most people don't want to see people suffer and be heard,
even though their religion might say,
you should stone somebody,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Most people are reasonable.
Most people are that way.
And,
and it is the loudest lunatic fringe that tends to sway the debate.
Look at this country,
look at the parties,
the Republican and Democratic Party.
Look at,
look at who really gets all the headlines.
It's allowed as motherfuckers.
Yeah.
And it's also if you grew up in that environment,
the reality is if that was your standard of behavior,
if you were around people like those guys in that video,
you know,
Hamani of fuel belong to regular mosque.
If you were,
if you around that guy,
you'd be like that guy.
That's the reality is we imitate our atmosphere or you or you would assume the
position when you're in church.
Then you go about your day and life is busy and you're like,
you know,
and in that sense,
uh,
I can see,
I totally see this pendulum swifty shifting back and forth in this,
this yes means yes,
I kind of see the origins of it and I kind of see like I see the whole thing
from a larger perspective,
but I just feel that as human beings trying to engineer our society that what we
should really be trying to do if it is at all possible,
is approach each other and approach these situations with kindness and
compassion and live off of and dignity and,
and friendship.
The idea that we could establish friendship and established that people who are
in certain situations do things that they regret,
whether it's a woman getting drunk,
having sex with a guy she didn't really want to have sex with after the fact
when she realized like,
what have I done?
Blow and,
but let's,
let's approach this with compassion.
Let's understand,
let's,
let's counsel these people to not get drunk and make poor choices.
Let's not turn the men into rapists or use that term where there are real
rapist.
There are people that fucking hate women and they want to hold him down and put
a knife to the neck and fuck them.
Just they can say they did it right because they're evil cunt,
right?
Those guys should be in jail.
But the guy who gets drunk and has sex with a girl who says,
uh,
do you have a condom?
And the guy says yes,
and then text her friend.
I'm coming over.
I'm going to go have sex with this guy.
That's not wait.
But that's just personal responsibility.
And to say that this young 18 year old guy is supposed to have more
responsibility in that scenario than the 18 year old girl.
He's totally sexist.
Yup.
Completely.
It's unfair,
unfair,
totally unfair and evil.
It's evil.
Yeah.
That's really sexist.
I mean,
that's like one of the most sexist approaches to,
to human beings,
enjoying each other's company that I could even imagine because you're dealing
with a completely even scenario,
a guy and a girl communicating that they want to be together.
The girl communicating to her friend,
she's about to go have sex saying,
I'm going to go have sex now.
Uh,
Francis Fukuyama who is the,
is
like,
you know,
Harold has this incredible intellectual,
just wrote this book.
Now it's coming out and you know,
he's just,
he said that,
that if you look at history,
it's,
it's been Manz,
Manz,
quest for dignity.
Like every culture,
every person that that's what people really strive for as nations,
as people.
Just the idea that they want some dignity.
They want some governance over their own body.
They want fair play.
They want to be heard.
They want to not be humiliated.
All those things.
And it's kind of an interesting thing if you think about it under under one
word,
what human beings really,
that human history has been sort of a march and a quest for dignity by people's
and by individual.
We're trying to engineer a more idealistic society.
Slowly but surely from the dark ages on to 2014 from the beginning of writing
shit down on animal skins,
trying to establish a set of moral principles based on the word of God or Allah
or Buddha or whoever the fuck you want.
We're trying to figure out a way to do things better.
Yeah.
And that's what we're still,
that's right.
And so a law like this,
the yes means yes.
Where they're trying to do,
they're trying to stop sexual assault on campus,
which is a real issue.
I,
I agree.
We're away.
Yes.
Right.
But,
but it's a question of what your methodology is and whether you're creating more
damage than good when you're being fair in this or not.
And I think that's where the debate has to start.
What is the common goal?
We don't want people to be raped.
We all agree with that.
If you're a reasonable person and a good guy,
and now the question is what's the best way to do that,
but how can anybody ever think that?
Getting people to say,
you know,
like say,
okay,
do you want to have sex with me?
Yes.
I want to say that's the only way to do what I want.
Romance Man.
What about movies?
Yeah.
What about the fun of it?
Like,
Whoa,
Holy Shit.
Look what we're doing.
This is crazy.
The Fun of kissing and then a girl reaches and grabs you dick and you're like,
well,
you didn't say are we going to have sex now?
There was no conversation,
so when you're kissing a girl and she just grabbed your Dick,
it's one of the greatest moments in life.
She's dally account.
It really is one of the greatest moments in life when you're not sure what's
going to happen.
You're young.
Kissing was on a date once with this girl and she was I,
it was done.
I thought,
wow,
whatever.
I took on a date and I was trapped pulling out all the stops.
You know,
talking about this headline about celebrities,
I know,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
It was all going well,
but she was like not impressed.
And so finally I was like,
all right,
this house,
it was in New York City.
I was gonna put her in a cab.
And she goes,
you put me in a cab.
And I went,
what do you mean?
She goes,
so that's it.
You put me in a cab,
you're wimping out.
I was like,
nevermind.
Cab driver will go without to my place.
I was like,
yeah,
those are the,
some of the greatest moments of your life as a young man.
Yeah.
Those are some fucking good in
times when it all works out.
I mean there's,
there's ones that work out terribly.
There's ones that you get together and you know,
you know,
one person says something stupid and the other person says something stupider
and you're like,
oh fuck,
we're in a fucking quagmire.
No one's getting out of this.
And can it work?
Personalities clash and it's,
you know,
it doesn't always work,
but when it does work,
God,
it's magic.
And to try to quantify that magic with a conversation of consent and people say,
well,
your romance is not as important as a woman's sexual sovereignty and you need to
establish the fucking,
the really gross voices in this are not even the women.
Because I think fundamentally a lot of women probably have a really hard time
understanding the male urge.
Just like fundamentally a man has a very difficult time truly conceptualizing
the idea that a woman wants to get pregnant,
you know,
the,
the urge to have a baby grow in your body's fundamentally a very difficult thing
for a guy to wrap his head around.
And so when a woman wants to like do something that's illogical to sort of
regulate male sexuality,
I almost kind of understand it and almost kind of look at it and I go,
well yeah,
I guess they just don't,
maybe they don't know what it's like to be a man,
you know?
But when a man steps in and starts saying a bunch of really illogical shit,
when a man starts being like taking radical feminist point of view,
that shit becomes a very offensive to me because then that's when I know what
you're really doing is you're,
you're trying to earn favor.
You're trying to establish this really unusually moral position.
Social branding,
social brownie points,
hashtags,
Hashtag male feminists and you know,
I mean look,
again,
we both have,
I don't want to call them feminists,
but we both have what we call humanist values.
Like I think absolutely everyone should be treated equally in,
in,
in the law,
right?
But we're not equal in society.
We're just not just like,
we're not equals stronger,
faster,
whatever.
Some people are smarter.
It's just the world is weird,
man.
Some people are tall,
some people are short,
some people were sexually attractive.
Some people,
people are not.
We're not equally funny.
Some people are not fucking funny.
They never will be.
Some people suck at math.
I'm one of them.
Some people know there's like a lot
of shit that's just not fair.
It's just the world.
The world is weird and when men come along and they want to establish some,
some weird fake male behavior rules,
and I know what they're doing when I know what they're doing,
when I know they're saying things and making videos about like that.
We'd talked about it on the fattiest Russell podcast,
that dear woman video.
Do you ever see the deer woman video?
Oh,
you've never seen it either?
No.
For Real.
It's Brent.
Jamie,
pull it up one more time.
One more.
One more time.
Just say for the folks at home that may not have seen it,
it's these guys who no woman in their right mind would ever want to touch.
Scott.
He's the guy.
Oh,
those guys.
Have you seen it?
Yes.
Yeah.
I've seen those guys have the perfect,
you don't have to thank you for your strength.
Yes,
thank you for your wonderful characteristics.
We apologize for all the men who have treated you poorly,
like what choking you when you asked to be choked when you get fucked.
There's reality of those cars.
Those men are traders.
Those men are gender traders and all of them to a man or women or men that women
want,
I wouldn't want to fuck right.
That's what they're trying to sit.
Or there's a couple of them that look like players in there that are just taking
that,
you know that stance.
Bad guys had passed creeper posters.
There's a lot of creepers out there,
man.
I'm,
who is it like Dante in,
in the,
in the inferno said he goes,
that imposter is when he created his image of hell,
which was a cone inverted cone.
And the very worst of the bottom of the center of the earth are murderers and,
and,
and sadistic killers and imposters imposters are actually down there with them.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that out there,
man.
There's a lot of both.
There's just a lot of,
again,
there's a lot of uneven in the world,
but there's a lot of people that are these member.
When do you ever see Peter Schiff?
When he was at occupy Wall Street,
there was a bunch of people that were,
uh,
on occupy Wall Street and he had this video.
Peter Shifts.
Brilliant Guy,
economist and I had him on the podcast.
Fascinating.
I don't necessarily agree with all of his points of view,
but he's a very bright man and he knows so much more about economics than I ever
will.
And he was talking to these people.
He set up a booth,
like a stand,
you know,
and had a big sign that said,
ask a one percenter and a,
if you've never seen it,
pull it,
pull that up because it's fucking amazing.
And it's these people that are angry man,
but their ideas are so uninformed,
poorly thought out and easily picked apart.
And one of those was like,
why do you need so much money,
man?
He's like,
I employed a hundred people.
Who Do you employ?
How many people do you employ?
How many people do you help?
Like you're,
you're asking me,
why do I need so much money?
Why do I make so much?
This is capitalism.
You're a capitalist too.
You're just not good at it.
You know,
like you do,
you pay money for food,
do you pay money for rent?
Well then you're a capitalist.
You get paid for work.
Do you get paid for work?
Yes,
you get paid for work.
You're a capitalist.
Like you're just not good at it.
Like I was incredible,
amazing.
Asked the 1% and I agree,
the sentiment
and I agree with the fact that you should be protesting.
It's just my point is it's Washington that should it be the recipient of the
protest.
You guys should be marching on to White House and the Federal Reserve demanding
your freedom back.
Look,
Steve Jobs just passed away.
He made billions.
How many people here have I phones in their pockets?
You know,
he's not a humanitarian.
He's a businessman.
He enriched the lives of millions of people pursuing his own self and not a ramp
that you can do an Ollie in front of your camera.
I actually want to have a conversation.
What the 99% to 1% meme was just one meme out of many names.
I'm so sorry.
A popular Turner phrase.
Okay,
so the,
the,
the catchphrase,
99% this is not 99% park.
It's Liberty Plaza and the 99% catch phrase is not definitive of everyone here.
It makes sense why a popularity meme would be popular.
I understand you have to make money,
but there's got to be regulations because I believe in democracy,
but I also believe in regulations.
The market has to grow at a sensible rate,
right?
You can not grow too fast.
If the market grows too fast,
it will crash.
See,
the regulation we want is the market.
That's the regulation that works.
The same thing is with Labor.
A corporation just can't take advantage of its workers and pay them as little as
it wants because businesses can eat with one another to by Labor.
He did a corporation and slavery.
Here we go.
Well,
what the slavery have to do with what we're talking about.
We're saying,
we're saying there,
there is a role for government in our society and incorporate bullet,
but slavery was wrong to begin with,
so let's not even,
it was government.
They created.
Government is there to protect property,
life,
liberty,
and that's it.
I mean,
you've mentioned Walmart,
so what are you afraid that Walmart's going to do to you?
What?
What am I afraid they're going to build?
What is Walmart?
You'd go and ask the employees that are working in sweatshops type conditions.
Don't get enough hours that don't have healthcare.
How isn't it?
Why don't they quit?
I mean,
Walmart doesn't hold a gun to their head.
If,
if they can get a better job.
So why did the rape victim get raped?
Who was she doing out late at night?
You want to go back to 1920 1930 I what does this golden year?
I don't want to help kids wanting to go back to,
I don't want,
well here the sixties the seventies I don't care.
I don't want to go back to that technology,
but I want to go back to that level of freedom.
I want the level,
it was more of Woo voted some point African Americans in.
Huh?
I know there's had to ride in the back and telling you you want to go back here.
We don't want to go back telling you there's more,
there's more economic freedom.
It was more economic,
social freedom and social justice.
There's been memorials for Steve jobs all over the place.
At every apple store,
every,
there's,
there's reporters that are all around the world that never asked one single
question to Steve jobs when he was alive.
Why are you manufacturing your iPhone in China and you don't have any of your
manufacturing?
He cannot tell you why.
Because we made.
I think that's fair to the American people.
The American people don't own those jobs.
Steve jobs has the right to manufacture where he wants.
He doesn't have a right to do it and the problem is we have made it too
expensive for him.
The manufacturer here with our,
we,
the governor.
Mexican workers want too much because the government much,
oh,
it's the member.
The reason that that employee employers,
right want a lower wages is because their customers want low prices.
Everybody in this park once low prices,
you can't have low prices.
No,
we don't.
Do you believe that the federal government has a right to exist in the governor
lives of it has the right to exist,
but not in the form.
It exists today.
It's operating outside.
The EPA should be disbanded.
I think it does a lot more harm than good.
Do you believe the FDA should be damned life and get rid of it?
What about the FDA?
The board?
I take the board of education.
We should,
I want about the board of education.
I want to get rid of the entire federal department of Education.
Yes,
it is wasting our money and it is running up the cost of education or what I've
learned with,
well,
let me finish.
What I've learned over the years is to never argue with a fool.
And You my friend or fool.
Okay,
so on the foolish,
right?
So I just stumbled into all my wealth.
I run all of these business units.
How can I say?
How could you disband the EPA and the EPA and the board of education or it's not
the border and you're talking about the department.
Well,
unity at
30% of the homeless people in America are veterans.
So when everybody says we support the troops,
that's a lie.
You support the troops when they're out there getting killed or shot.
But when they come home and they're homeless and they got no jobs,
you don't support the truth.
I didn't even know.
And that's why why didn't even support a lot of these wars then put those trips
over there in the first place.
But all right,
this guy's crazy.
Okay,
you want it to change it all that you guys are the ones,
or at least he's got his hand on Wall Street,
are the ones that are funding all the campaigns that putting these people in
power in the first place and then you do so because you know that they will
enact policies that you want.
And then you also know that once they do that and you become friends with them
through campaign fundraising and all that,
and that is the problem,
that they will make you into government and you'll be like,
hey,
can I,
can I be secretary of the Treasury?
If they had no power,
there'd be no lobbying.
They'd have beat,
there'd be nothing to give out.
We don't want the government to be able to pick winners and losers to say you
get a bail out and you don't.
You get,
you pay a tax and you get a subsidy.
That is the problem.
Is this one guy that I actually wanted you to focus on that it was like he was
asking him,
why do you need so much money?
Why can't you make $10 million instead of $100 million?
You're talking about glasses.
He can't the rocks.
Such an example of of with you hold the point of view.
It takes a long time to earn it.
What the bank does with your money when you deposited there.
Do you care about the loan?
I do.
Why do you worry?
You might be a different one here.
There's a bunch of these videos.
Gutsy guy.
I love that he did this though.
He's,
he's
got,
is it two hours?
Yeah.
Oh Jesus Christ.
It's the wrong one.
There's one that was a short,
classic example of like you might be angry.
I understand,
but it's exactly the great Thoreau quote.
I see men everywhere hacking at the branches of evil while none are striking the
route.
And if you,
if you want to say something's evil,
if it's Wall Street,
if it's big Pharma,
if it's whatever,
it's so crucial to to establish what you,
what kind of evil and the way you figured that out is who is the real enemy?
What is the root cause?
That's why you've got to read.
That's why you've got to earn your opinion.
Otherwise you're just shouting in the wind
and you're telling me that you can have a conversation like this where one guy
has a microphone,
he's going back and forth handing it to you and to you and you're doing it in a
video clip and you're saying,
you know,
I want to end this.
I want to end that.
I want to end up department of Education.
You're a fool.
Okay,
we didn't get anything done here too.
People shouting.
Their point would be to really establish what is wrong with the Department of
Education.
You have to have a long nuance conversation about what they're doing with how
they're funded,
what the problem is,
how they subsidize college tuition so that it costs so much more for you to
actually go to college.
The reason why it's so God damn expensive,
and it would be different if this didn't exist and you know,
talking to people who know their shit and reading the right
books who make a good argument is,
is how you get closer.
At least investigation over some time is,
hey,
get closer to figuring out where the real problem.
Yeah,
it's the emotions that flare up when people start talking about things and they
don't really have an educated opinion on them.
They just go there because they know something's wrong.
I equated occupy Wall Street to like white blood cells and I'm like,
they know there's an effect infection,
so they all circle around this area of infection,
but it's not really effect that they're really,
really good metaphor for that because you're right,
it was,
it was a combination of a lot of things,
but it wasn't effective.
It's like they got there and the like,
Ooh,
this is a fucking infection.
We're white blood cells.
But nothing really got done other than expose.
Well one thing did get done it,
it opened up the dialog,
but the dialog was already opened up and people understood the bail out,
bail out bro and
broken.
Didn't know why,
you know,
but,
but yes,
it's,
it's why,
you know,
there are some very important and very challenging problems in the world and
there are people out there that are coming up with good answers.
But unfortunately,
and one of the things that's beautiful about a podcast,
what I tried to do with mine,
what you certainly do with yours too,
very good,
is that a lot of really good ideas are stuck in books.
And I think that that technology,
podcasting,
if it's done responsibly and a lot of other,
a lot of other venues,
but it's especially is how you get those ideas out of those books.
Most of us don't have that much time to read.
Men.
We don't.
And I sympathize that.
I get it.
It's really hard to formulate an educated opinion on shit.
You and I know that.
You know,
like how many opinions that we'd have when we started doing podcasting and then
I get corrected
on this podcast,
my podcast,
I'd come up with a point of view and say something and people would be like,
by the way,
uh,
you're a little bit wrong on this.
And I'd go,
I've been holding that belief for 10 fucking years.
And when you start to really investigate and try to come up with a really sound,
strong political philosophy,
business philosophy,
life philosophy,
it takes a lot of fucking work and try harder.
It's hard to let go of opinions,
but don't stop trying to come up with the answer.
A lot of people do not ever want to let go of their opinions.
Once they have that opinion,
that motherfucker is locked in because they form an emotion around it.
That's why,
because it's exactly like talking to somebody.
When you see a religious person talked to an atheist,
the atheist says,
God doesn't exist.
The religious person goes,
wait a minute.
My religion gives me a feeling.
And a very good feeling.
It makes me feel like there's purpose and meaning in my life.
This guy's attacking that and then it becomes about that.
It becomes not about religion.
It becomes,
you're trying to take the feeling I have away from me.
Fuck you.
Well,
it's also I opinions are very hard to let go of.
Yeah.
It's all,
it's also when people are having conversations a lot of times and not just
expressing each other and exchanging information or expressing themselves,
exchanging information.
They're also trying to win.
You know,
they're trying to be one with the correct information,
the trying to be the smarter person and sometimes they're doing it about stuff
they don't really fucking have any information about,
but they're still in there swinging like flailing away,
like doesn't know how to fight.
Who gets in fights.
I mean,
if you ever seen a person who's not,
we all have,
yes,
I've talked about it on this podcast,
this terrifying scenario that happened one night in front of the comedy store
when I saw this guy get in a fight with this guy who didn't have any fucking
skill at all.
He didn't know what to do.
He didn't know how to handle panic and he was his eyes closed.
He was flailing and a bus pulled in front of me.
I couldn't see what happened.
You know that because you know they were fighting on one side of the street and
a bus blocked my vision and then when the bus passed he was out cold on the
concrete.
So obviously somebody punched him,
but the guy didn't know how to fight,
but yet he was still fighting.
And some people will get in arguments about some shit they don't have any
information about.
They don't have nothing,
but they have a point.
I have an opinion and an attitude that is based on something that happened to
them at an emotional thing.
We all have some of that in us.
I certainly do and I've worked very hard to try to let go of that shit when I'm
in an argument and I sometimes I had to check myself and go,
man,
I'm arguing to be right here because this person's attacking something else
inside of me I'm not even aware of or whatever.
And you see it in relationships.
I got to,
I got to check myself and my relationship.
Sometimes we'll just start having an argument and I'm just pissed off and I want
to have an argument because I feel like I want to be right about this subject
and when I take a step back,
a lot of times it's really hard to do,
but it's really important to them as you go.
You know what?
I actually don't know that much.
Sometimes someone will say something crazy to you and instead of saying,
wait a minute,
why'd you say you'll say something crazy back in the next thing you know?
It's a fucking avalanche of crazy.
Both of your swinging,
swinging into the air and emotional and fucking can't
breathe good.
It's also really fuck.
It's also really important to identify what you mean by x.
What do you mean by God?
What do you mean by religion?
What do you mean by first before we start,
let's,
let's know what we agree on and it's,
I like politics.
I love the argument now that I have with politics is this,
I don't talk about Republican,
Democrat,
liberal,
conservative.
I like the question of we know that you need some governance.
Of course you need some governance in a society.
The debate really revolves around to what percent,
how much,
how much do you want government running your lives?
There's an answer and some people want more.
There's just an answer.
How to what degree in what aspect?
It's a complicated question but start the debate and the discussion that way and
you'll get further along.
I like having my mind changed.
I like listening.
Like you were talking the other day and you were explaining like where
technology was going and I had a lot of opinions so I've been reading the same
shit and I was about to jump in with a bunch of my points as well,
but then I was like,
wait,
let me just listen to this and I learned some shit that I didn't know before.
It's a new thing for me,
man.
This is a nice thing for you.
A little bit like to really listen and key into what somebody's saying and say
and look for something new and look for something that you might not know
instead of trying to add to the conversation.
Hey,
by the way,
guys,
this is something I know as well.
We all do that.
We fucking do that all the time.
Everybody does it.
Oh Joe saying this,
let me add,
let me add this to it.
Let me put a cherry on that Sunday for you guys to show you that I'm also
knowledgeable and smart,
you know,
instead of just king and maybe not saying anything.
You know what I like,
you know,
I like what answer I liked from people and lot of times what do you think of
this?
And a lot of people go,
I don't know.
It's good enough.
That's a good answer.
That's good.
That's very important.
Very,
very important.
Being able to say you don't know,
that's like,
why is that hard for people?
It's hard because we equate our knowledge,
like how much knowledge we have with a strongly are.
Yeah.
And we all know some of the week or per,
yeah,
and our personal,
our personal opinion of them ourselves.
But we're coming to find out,
especially in this day and age,
it's one of the good things about things like Google.
You can't know everything.
You cannot,
I've had fucking conversations with people where they seem fairly intelligent
and then they'll say something,
they'll want to have a conversation about martial arts and they'll say something
so off base and so ridiculous.
Then now I have to question everything that they've said before
that into my world.
And you stepped into my world acting like,
you know what the fuck you're talking about while I go,
well,
how many of these other things you've told me your bullshit too.
That's so disappointing.
I've had that happen to me where people will say something and you go,
you're really smart and a lot of stuff and you just stepped into a different
arena.
You're,
you're,
uh,
you're in the middle of the ocean with no boat.
Right?
It's one of the few things where I'll just completely stop the conversation.
I go,
no,
stop.
Yeah.
I just,
I get offended when people start talking about like cheese and you know,
it's about,
it's about your centering your energy and some people can't be pushed over.
Please shut the fuck up and your lane,
you want to see something amazing.
Now that is real.
Some real martial arts shit that is kind of like magic.
Yes.
Jamie,
there's a video on my,
um,
uh,
Twitter feed that's from today and is from a long time ago from,
I think it was a 1950s,
this fucking old man doing judo with his top students.
And this old dude is like,
I don't know how old he is at the time,
but he's fucking old.
He's old and it's,
he is,
he's really frail looking.
Go full screen on this is this fucking incredible man.
I mean is this is a really incredible to watch it does it say how old he is in
this video?
If he looks like a stamp,
Dan preparing to challenge,
uh,
he's,
he's perfect for a challenge with high level students.
Now Watch,
watch what the fuck happens,
man.
This is a tiny little old man and this isn't bullshit.
Okay.
I know bullshit and I know choreography.
I'm watching this judo and these guys are really trying to throw this dude,
but check this out.
Look at this whole,
Oh,
amazing.
She's perfect technique.
It has legs.
Go flying up in the air.
Look at this,
how he resists the technique looking effortless.
Almost.
This guy's trying to throw him.
Fuck yeah,
he is.
He's trying to throw them,
but the old man knows exactly how to position himself.
Watch,
look,
see,
he goes behind the hip every time.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
And watch these,
these young guys,
these young black belts are watching this.
This guy is old as fuck.
He's much smaller,
but watch how he throws him.
It's incredible.
He finds the moon.
Look at this.
Every time he tries to throw him,
oh,
and then he,
they bow to each other and then the next guy comes along and this guy is fucking
tiny man.
This old dude is PR.
I mean,
I don't know how big the other guy is,
but he's significantly smaller than the other guy.
It's hard because we're not standing there and perspective,
but we're watching this little old man get rag dog.
It's crazy.
But when he gets picked in the,
I look at how he just goes with it.
He,
me,
he looked at that guy fucking tried Sam and the old man just,
just flowed with them,
just got behind his hips and stayed relaxed.
Like that relaxed,
stay relaxed.
The guy tried,
he's,
it's wrong.
You can see okay is 100% but look at this,
boom.
The old man waits for his moment and throws him.
I mean it's,
it's brilliant.
It's amazing to watch.
And Jews like a watermelon.
Juno's one of the roughest when it comes to like martial arts on your body.
So watching this old really old man throw these young cats around is incredibly
impressive because of the fact that it's so physically dependent.
I mean you see like the really great judoka is like,
like look in the UFC like Hector,
oh the old dude sent that guy fly in shit.
I mean,
these are shit.
It's incredible,
right?
Whoa,
this is fucking amazing.
Me Look,
look,
look.
And he was like a movie.
Yeah.
Look how he goes with it.
When the guy tries to throw him,
he just goes and he's in perfect position every time was hips.
Yeah.
He just his hips,
her.
It's positioning.
Look at that.
Oh like I was going to say,
and these are,
by the way,
these are man,
I don't know what kind of floor that is,
but that's not like modern fucking mad at floors would probably hard as shit.
Like Hector Lombard,
like us physical specimen,
Ronda Rousey physical specimen and these are like great judoka is that are in
mixed martial arts today.
You know?
And there's a lot of like their explosion,
their ability to close the distance and execute techniques that can be
attributed to this power and athleticism.
But this old dude ain't got none of that man.
Cause Juno,
if you watch it like in the Olympics,
it's so explosive.
It's like boom.
It's like so quick.
It's amazing.
Let's do,
it's like water.
He's literally like a ghost.
Yeah.
It's incredible,
man.
It's incredible to watch.
Have you ever seen me dance?
Show up some video that I would,
I really wish I knew more about this dude.
How when this was filmed,
what is this called?
This a video.
It says amazing old judo throw defense.
The guy's name is [inaudible],
E accepts challenges from high level students.
It's incredible.
Look at that guy's really trying course he is.
Of course he is.
I mean you could see the effort and he's doing the right thing to me.
The guy who is trying is a fucking high level judoka himself.
Like,
look how he's throwing these techniques.
He's trying these hip tosses and he's not getting anywhere with it.
Just got ridiculous haircut.
That guy,
the old look at this,
the whole guy just,
he keeps getting behind his hips.
You see how he places his weight every time.
It's just like,
oh shit.
Oh my main man,
he can see his opening.
You got guys a one as the first,
Dan,
he's a first degree black belt and this guy's an eighth degree black belt here,
but the old man's a 10.
So this guy right here is like probably the highest level student that he's uh,
done it against in this video.
But it's just,
it just shows how technique is everything.
It's so fucking important.
And athleticism with great technique is almost unbeatable.
It's one of the reasons why a guy like Lombard is so good.
It's because he has both of those,
his technique,
his lumbar.
I would say if he saw this,
like what?
Amazed.
Well,
judoka is a very proud of judo,
judo gene and the bells.
Very proud of it.
And Rhonda is proud of it.
In a judo is a fucking hard martial art man.
It's hard on the body,
very difficult to learn and it requires a great deal of understanding,
understanding of the mechanics of the body and leverage.
And Rhonda.
Rhonda told me she was like 11 and her,
she broke her toe and she was crying and her mother made her run laps or mother
goes,
you might break your toe competition or on labs.
She was just like,
yeah,
she's a little bad ass.
Her mother's a hard woman.
Yeah,
but look what she created.
Oh,
she created an extreme winter.
You know what's interesting is Rhonda is going to uh,
you know,
she's going to defend her title against Cat Zingano and if she beats cat
Zingano.
Um,
Cyborg is scheduled to fight as 135 pounder for the first time in December in
Invicta.
Invicta was as an all female mixed martial arts league and the Cyborg is the 130
545 pound champ.
She's dropping down to one 35 for the first time.
It's fucking very hard cut.
But like a lot of these people that may,
we did some questionable things that made them get larger.
Maybe your farm,
can they lose weight and then they become smaller and you know,
I mean maybe a different human being.
Maybe it'd be easier for her now to drop that way.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know,
but it's um,
it's certainly a very fucking compelling matchup cause Cyborg,
well there was a picture of her and her husband,
uh,
from behind her back was about as wide as her husbands and her husband was a
stud.
I mean,
he was a wide,
thick,
strong,
big thick gal.
Yeah.
But you know,
if you do hardcore cardio like marathon running and shit like that,
your body will automatically shed this shed you atrophy of the muscle and you're
going to start slimming down.
Just change your diet.
You can force yourself to lose weight.
You mean you can only force yourself to lose a certain amount and still be
athletically competitive.
But she's still doing strength and conditioning exercises.
She's still doing all sorts of things that build muscle.
And if she didn't,
if she really wanted to drop down to 135 pounds,
you'd have to diminish her body mass.
Who,
who that,
you know,
fighter wise,
I was thinking about Bj Penn,
but who you know,
who's really done the fun and the most drastic weight categories like the most
DJ fought heavyweight and then fought featherweight.
He fought how much do you weight when he fought Hattaway,
but he fought,
um,
who's probably one 90 something here.
Maybe.
Maybe it was a little bit heavier than that,
but when he fought Leo Machida Machida was over two oh five.
So Machida was tactically heavyweight.
Crazy.
Yeah,
I dunno what Machida wage does.
Not Tall.
I mean he's,
no,
it's short.
It's a fucking animal though in its best.
And his prime,
he was a fucking animal.
Um,
but I think that he's probably the biggest example of a,
of a high level guy that's fought.
I mean obviously Machita went on to be the light heavyweight champion and is a
contender right now in the middle weight division.
And Bj just fought as a featherweight,
so it's fucking,
he's got the most drastic changes.
Any follow up as to like a lot of people are really surprised by when he was
fighting frank,
Frankie Edgar and his last fight,
he,
his feet were so close to getting her and he's on his toes.
It was very strange.
Yeah.
Was there,
was there ever,
was that ever addressed by them or by anybody else?
Yeah,
he said he was trying to conserve energy and then he decided that that was a
stance that he was going to adopt because,
and keeping his legs wide and like pushing off with his legs,
that it would require too much energy.
He's always had a problem with stamina,
you know,
that's,
that's been his problem and he was,
he was ferocious in the first round of the second fight with Matt Hughes or the
third fight sacrament.
Yeah,
we were fighting last second fight,
third fight.
He knocked him out.
He was out.
It was ferocious in the first round and then ran out of gas in a second.
Matt.
He started beating them down the second round and it was,
cause Matt Hughes was in better shape.
Bj at his best was when he was training with the Marinovich is because,
uh,
Marinovich has we're fucking animals.
When it came to strength and conditioning and they got him in unbelievable
shape.
He was just shredded.
He had abs is finding 155 pounds.
He was strong and like when he beat Joe Stevenson,
when he beat a Diego Sanchez at 155 pounds,
he was the best.
He was at his best and he was just in incredible shape.
He was a monster there,
but it was conditioning.
Just,
you know,
lives a good life.
It lives in Hawaii.
He's got plenty of money.
He's a hero.
He goes to Hawaii everywhere he goes.
Bj is awesome.
They love him.
It was very difficult for a guy that lives in silk sheets to get up and go to
war every day.
That's the reality of life.
Yeah,
it's hard and really loved guy who also is supreme.
Lee physically talented and people don't know that.
He's a prime to Jay that nicknamed the prodigy.
It came because he won the world championships after three years of training in
Jujitsu.
But I've heard other fighters like Eve Edwards in those guys tell me that they'd
never seen anybody pick up a technique that quickly.
So when you're an MMA fighter,
you know like picking up a technique,
whatever it might be,
it takes a while.
You got to drill,
it takes a long time.
It's,
and that's,
it can take up to a year or you know,
four months,
five months that Duke could see it twice.
And it was part of his repertoire.
Well he was,
I don't want to say he was a natural fighter,
but that was something that he had a lot of passion for and he was very focused
about it.
And it came,
it came pretty quickly to them.
But there's a lot other guys that have a slowly dropped weight and McVie tore,
fought as heavy as 240 at one point in his career when he fought Randy coture,
I think he was like two 40 something and now he's much thinner now.
Man,
he's,
now that he's off the TRT,
he,
you know,
he's really looking thin.
It's just like there's been a lot of people that is frame was like one 80.
I mean if you look at his hands and feet,
they're not big.
No.
Well there's a lot of people that think you can make welterweight weight,
especially now that he's off TRD then yeah,
there's videos of him working out.
There's a recent video on his Instagram and uh,
it went on the underground.
Like people were looking at it and they're like,
seriously,
I'm not bullshitting.
I think he could be a welterweight.
And we look at some welterweights like,
okay,
here's the perfect example,
Carlos condit,
he's a big boy,
you know,
look at some of the gods.
Like,
okay,
Tyron Woodley,
Tyrone Woodley is up big fucking guy.
He's a shit.
And he manages to get down to one 70.
Vito doesn't look that big and not now what is I'm Carlos condit way you think
on the off season,
he's probably bordering the nineties like gets around one 90 close to it.
15 pounds,
20 pounds over the weight limit.
Handsome kid too.
Good looking guy.
Yeah,
he's,
I'm recovering from knee surgery.
Tore his ACL against Woodley.
So damn good.
Carlos condit is just so good.
Yeah.
Talk about conditioning and that doodle fight,
a five round fight or I don't know if he had had to funnel five rounder.
Yes.
Yay.
Fought GSP is a five round fight and you know,
he just,
he just is gone practically at the same pace.
We were watching Rory Macdonald knocked out tax happening this week and we were
watching the highlights of it.
Robin,
my friend Robin Black,
we'll also has been on the podcast,
did a breakdown of it and uh,
he did an awesome breakdown of it and really highlighted some of the,
uh,
the things that Rory did really well in that fight and things at Safa.
Nene did to try to like throw Roy off.
It didn't work.
But I'm Rory Macdonald's another one at one 70.
That's fucking terrifying.
And the interesting,
interesting guy,
man,
you know,
it was training with GSP for a long time and then as they got further along in
their career,
it started getting the talk about like these guys I'd eventually fight now that
GSPs retired and he's like one of the number one contenders now.
He's,
that was one of the most impressive things I've ever seen.
The,
his,
his ability to stand there with Saffie and it's feed him at his own game.
I mean,
real beautiful.
It's just incredible.
I mean,
you look at what Safa Dean,
when Stephanie and fight fought Nate Marquardt how well he did against Mark
Clark and then see Rory pick them apart like that.
It's incredible.
Check the leg kicks stint standing outside and delivering his own leg kicks.
Yup.
Yeah.
Amazing.
And that Jab and that,
ah,
just the way he knocked him down.
Yeah.
Were always a mother fucker.
It said it's such an exciting sport,
but it's another thing we were talking about in camp.
It was really interesting.
We were talking about um,
the reality of these guys damaging themselves.
You know,
like Brian and I were at the airport yesterday in Seattle and we were watching a
football game and we don't particularly watch football that often.
So we're watching it,
which is all,
I could see what these guys heads colliding.
That's just tunc those helmets colliding with each other.
And all I could think about was that recent NFL study that showed that 76% of
deceased NFL player 76 at a 79 had brain injuries like significant 7,679 brains
they studied,
had to sit down and brain injury.
Significant brain damage.
Well then you're starting to see it.
You see Tony Doerr set and you see these guys try Montana trying to talk really
seven.
Yeah,
he's having issues with his memory.
Um,
uh,
what's the fucking guy?
Yeah,
Brett Farve was having real issues,
right?
Um,
well he,
it was Brett Farve never took a day.
I mean,
Brett Farve had the longest run.
he was the iron man.
I mean,
he was fighting.
He was getting knocked on his ass by the biggest,
toughest guys.
Never broke a bone.
I mean,
he's just,
the superman got addicted to painkillers,
I believe for a while.
That has no surprise.
I mean,
that guy put himself through punishment.
Like no football player I've ever seen.
I mean,
he was the guy from Chicago bears from the 80s.
Uh,
Julia Mann,
Jim Mcmahon,
Cim.
Mcmahon's got some serious issues.
Now,
and he talks about how sometimes it'd be in his house and have no idea what he
was about to do or where he's going.
He knows.
He just doesn't know what he's doing.
He's just standing there like,
what am I doing?
Yeah.
And he was a on a sports radio show and he was talking about it in depth.
It was a cover of sports illustrated,
him and his issues.
It's soured me to the game.
I'll be honest with you.
I used to watch football all the time and the more I learn,
I'm like,
ma'am,
I don't really want to some,
I dunno.
What about MMA?
Um,
because look,
let's be realistic.
I feel like it's not as,
uh,
it's that I feel like,
and it's changing because the training,
but I feel like that head trauma isn't a sustain.
It isn't like football or boxing.
Am I wrong?
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
um,
especially because so much emphasis is on stand up these days.
And it used to be,
there was a recent Andrew interview,
um,
with um,
Dan Hardee and Dan Hardee was talking about,
uh,
you know,
Dan had a heart condition,
not a real heart,
a very controversial situation where he's very fit and healthy,
but he has like an extra heartbeats something wolf condition.
I forgot what it's called,
but he was talking about how when he was fighting it was a lot of wrestlers that
were dominating the 170 pound division.
And now there's a lot of kickboxers.
Now you've got Roy McDonald,
now you got,
you know,
Robbie Lawler,
you've got a lot of strikers wound up strikers,
bombs.
Well guys who can wrestle and it can do all those things,
but a lot of kickboxing techniques are starting to dominate these contests.
And when you're training a lot of kickboxing,
you've got a lot of head injuries.
There's a lot of head trauma that's going on both in training and in fights.
It's always changing too.
I mean,
I,
I've never seen the block that Rory Macdonald was using that high elbow bladders
seen that very smart,
very well.
It's very smart to avoid strikes to the head,
especially if you know that a guy is throwing head punches,
you know,
and a lot of these guys,
they're,
they're not throwing the type of like really long form combinations that you
will see high level Moitai or high level Dutch kickboxers throw the throwing one
or two techniques.
And a lot of it is because you're worried about takedowns you're,
what we're seeing is just an evolution of the game we're seeing seeing the sport
evolve.
I love it.
I mean,
I'm a huge fan,
but it concerns me.
Brain damage is a very,
very,
uh,
it's a very real thing and there's no turning back.
That's what bugs me the most.
You could go get me out on
bigger gloves.
I mean,
no,
that's not going to help that I might even hurt actually.
The solution might actually be no gloves.
That might be a better solution when it comes to head trauma because you can't
hit his heart without breaking your hands.
You have to be much more selective in your punch placement.
You go out faster in a weird way too,
right?
I mean,
well,
I don't know about that.
I think you probably go out harder and faster with the UFC gloves because they
pad your knuckles.
He could punch harder and you're also,
you're supporting the wrist,
you taping the risks down.
I think realistically you shouldn't be able to tape your wrists.
He should be able to take your hands and I think that would probably be one of
the best ways to protect against head trauma.
Still though,
it's like,
you know,
you know as well as I do.
You put on headgear and you get hit with somebody wearing boxing gloves.
Your spine,
you get hit,
you got headgear.
I wear a bar,
they call me a pussy.
I got a bar.
Then I get hit just in the top of the head I got a headache.
Why?
Because my head got jam back in.
My brain was mushed around and I was like,
what am I doing to even shop?
Brennan shop was like,
what are you doing?
You wouldn't want to do this.
Do you not have to fight
or you're an actor.
Why Sparring?
I was like,
oh,
I don't know.
Cause you're wanting to do it.
He is.
He's like,
he literally wouldn't when an MMA fighter and he's,
your friend comes up and goes,
do you don't,
what are you doing?
You don't need to do this.
Maybe you should stop.
Oh you mean I'm 47?
Yeah.
Okay.
I think I will.
Well,
you should go see Brian Cowen and see this idiot inaction.
Hey,
see it at its best.
Tobar 16,
17 and 18 at the Atlanta Improv and uh,
yeah,
it would be awesome.
Do you know his work?
Leo Flowers?
A really funny comic coming down the future for me and uh,
I'm excited to just go to Brian.
count.com.
Brian B R
y a n.com.
[inaudible] B r y a n Callan c a l l e n.com and a,
I'm at the tower theater in Philadelphia August,
October rather 17th with Ian Edwards.
And I'm at the Warner Theater October 18th with Ian Edwards in Washington DC.
That's it.
Lots of podcasts this week.
I got honey,
honey.
Anthony Kumi is going to be here and Keith Weber as well.
The,
uh,
the guy from the kettle bell cardio workout that I,
that I talk about so much that I love,
he'll be here.
So,
uh,
until then,
enjoy your lives,
my friends.
And it's great to be back at civilization.
Big Kissy.
Assume,
Jeez.